yes alors aujourd'hui on va présenter la
deuxième demi-finale du speech à sa
belle chips qui
qui verra affronter le grand vainqueur
de 3,64 nakamura contre le numéro trois
mondial ding
donc qu'est ce que tu penses de ce match
de sa vie
sur le papier cette racaille largement
favori andy triple tenant du titre je
crois après deal sa gamme genre hyper
précieux auxiliaires dans un bon jour il
peut faire douter s'il avance avant les
pulls est pourquoi pas cornet espère que
ce soit à un match à sens unique parce
sont tous vu l'horaire d'apport où
vivent
pas de commenter un match où il ya
quatre cinq points d'écart
ouais alors bon généralement on est
toujours en train d'essayer de défendre
le joueur qui n'est pas favori avant
l'été pour ça arrive on a toujours été
pour des joueurs mais là aujourd'hui je
suis plutôt pour demain car voix parce
que bon sur a relaté en blitz et j'aime
vraiment beaucoup ce joueur sa manière
de jouer enfin juste très très
impressionnant d'un cas moi et donc sur
le papier en termes fidh nakamura
managent plus gros échecs mais bon il a
taquiné le top top niveau un top 10
beaucoup de soin et digne des gommes
dures honneur au mondial ait 2119
correctement son vélo au max donc
c'était c'est pas mal de 820 quasiment
et ding et malgré un numéro trois
mondial ça fait quelques années
maintenant qu'il entre 2 et 3 et donc il
est très solide à ce niveau et et mais
on a lu quelques sur internet c'est pas
forcément sa spécialité
mais c'est vrai comme du l'alien
dim sur un bon jour il peut vraiment
qu'elle essuierait raboté d'un cas
lorsque au final c'est quand même un des
meilleurs joueurs du monde on va voir un
petit peu comment ça se passe alors
saluons fabien et salue déceptive salut
à vous merci de
me tenir compagnie se savent aspect
tellement arc égard il faut que vous
soyez avec nous
jusqu'au bout ce soir alors ça commence
par une sorte de
rester si le bon qui se transforme en
catalan du tout
à la main de la catalane
basse et des bonnets sont qui qui se
joue en fait
qu'un peu plus de vie là-dedans la queue
dans un
dans un berlin ou dans un centre uc
comme ça
oui même s'il ya une certaine symétrie
en tout cas dans la barbe ou qu'ils ont
choisi en tout cas moi je pense que dit
mme yan bin du club un petit peu se
préparer sérieusement et canada y va
comme d'habitude je m'étais ouverture on
note juste pour sortir ces pièces vers
une partie d'échecs ouais moi je pense
que d'un cas ils sont fous je pense pas
que ce soit le joueur vraiment à ce
retard est bon il va vraiment charmant
plus mais je pense pas que ce soit le
joueur qui viennent avec une grosse
préparation alors que dit que je pense
qu'il est plus sérieux ne veut plus
discuter de manière générale mais les
chinoises ouais voilà
la livre connaissent dit quoi
salut les gars salut à tous bienvenue
sur le tchat
on est là pour trois heures et demie
c'est ça
15h30 à peu près à clé pose donc lavées
pause ils ont raccourci les pauses des
pauses sont de 6 minutes bon c'est pas
mal mais la tendance ouest entre 6 et 8
ne savait pas trop et là c'est la face
du monde et reggae on va gagner 2 + 2 +
ça fait six minutes
donc ok dans cette position allait à peu
près à faire l'écrivain américain et
voyez les pions sont symétriques
des blancs leurs cases noires ont leurs
cadres cacace b5 éventuellement pour le
grand carré des blancs qui peut être
intéressante
mais bon c'est un élément aussi la carte
de 4 pour l'instant on voit pas trop
trop de
normes a dit d'égaliser confortablement
pour participer à ce tournoi et comme le
dit des 792 même thème j'aime c'est pas
sûr que ça suffise à ou animale au
mondial
pas évidemment pas ouvert à tous
parce que risque pour moi il est
ceinture noire il est allé mieux ce
direct a donc là combien tu avais 16
joueurs au début ce sont ces joueurs
avaient 16 joueurs donc
tu as le choix du 16 juin ils vont
prendre le meilleur qu'on est encore il
ya pas quand ce n est pas né pauvre
puisqu'ils je plains du monde ouais mais
trois places genre ah tu peux gagner en
qualifications et le reste c'est que des
invitations
demande pardon
le charpentier
ouais donc j'imagine tu n'as que sarine
par exemple s'est qualifiée par un
parent fiscalité comme d'hab' est invité
stein il a gagné le speech s junior sert
le même tournoi mais avec les moins de
20 ans ou qui s'est qualifiée comme ça
et vers notre qualifiés qui s'était
d'ailleurs
je fais un événement un peu comme les
title tuesday un truc à part et le
régime côté indication donc et puis on a
vu fillon roja en fait qu'il devait
lever martin la veille de son match au
dernier moment finalement après avoir
bien conscience il a décidé d'annuler
essais rapporte le la en place
et on voit moi je pense que fuel là on
ne verra quasiment plus sur les sur les
tournois internet parce que là on voit
déjà il a refusé de jouer le speech est
ce donc je sais pas si c'est lié ou pas
là bien sûr mais même sur un vrai ton
vaut quasiment plus
et c'est vrai que bon maintenant il ya
2008 104 lots il est numéro deux mondial
bon je pense qu'il va champion du monde
et internet pour lui c'est je pense un
peu être un peu nocifs un bain c'est un
divertissement quoi donc faux pas y'a
pas prendre trop au sérieux
oui voilà bien faste dans laquelle il
est concentré sur
le champ libre aux risques comment ça va
charmer maurice parce que tu sais qui
c'est sandy morris
je les cieux car charlie déjà charlie
charlot ça lui va bien les deux copains
et munitions qui n'avaient pas beaucoup
d'amoureux
alors j'ai il est breton
qui semble s est vu leurs filets comment
qu'est ce qui se passe bas généralement
il fait perez à 21h30 22h on s'inquiète
ça m'a mis le doute j'ai vu leur nom je
pense qu'il a il a dû prendre des
vitamines pour être ce soir mais je
pense qu'il va nous va pas durer dans le
temps
ne va pas durer non pour ce soir
alors pour répondre à kawa requis oui là
c'est les demies c'est la deuxième demi
finale la première demi finale c'était
c'était sarine contre sow et sow qui a
gagné 4,15 14 à 1.1 point d'écart et
donc qualifiés pour la finale sont donc
saut je pense regarde le match ou pas
t'en fous je sais pas mais je pense
qu'ils regardent le match et je vois
contre le vainqueur de celui là
donc avoir quand même que les deux
joueurs auront des lots qui sont
hallucinants tu vois nakamura 3200 vélo
et tu vois dit mme irène 3134 ça calme
quand même même si
3270 j'avais regardé ces
3360 comme ça où ça je peux regarder
rapidement mais
mais c'est quoi son vainqueur
32 sein du site anglais
3332 c'est juste elle
alors qu'ils favoris alors sur le papier
dans ce format en blitz sur internet
c'est senna camorra qui aime le voir
rien donc quelques attributions
jusque-là de speechless de matinée 3
bon la fin du monde car nous sommes en
finale
voilà
c'est le gagner quand tu as yannis hâlas
face à lucho ni
l'autre ganis
il ya une question qui étaient des deals
est haut par rapport à fear où est ce
que steve forrest gm si le passé moins
de temps que ça s'arrête
est-ce qu il serait ami et déjà
cette question est-ce que je peux virer
son message
c'est une blague et il ya de bonnes
chances au service si j'avais passé
un petit peu plus de temps à travailler
les échecs et à lire des bouquins plutôt
que de baisser cinq heures par jour
comme le faisait quand j'étais plus
jeune
peut-être que j'aurais pu être plus fort
que je suis actuellement tef les niçois
steph les niçois surplec cesse il ya il
ya 15 ans
15 hockey
tout est fort que moi que tu peux pas
lutter hors cac valeo prend des quatre
hyper intéressant prêtrise prise prise
rachat et d'un maire de québec qu'on
trouvera pas son mandat mais faisons
attention
madame pourquoi f4 aussi d'un 1er 2e et
le manger plus mais avec quatre ans fait
certain que cavaliers et ça m'a l'air
plus concret un
ouais ouais j'allais voir la maison
maintenant d'un f3 mais durant la pièce
ah ouais c'est vrai que c'est un bon
match il agit sur les côtes a raison
mais c'est la plus belle affiche sur le
papier qu'on a eu depuis début mai
clairement avoir seeding du cours répond
présent là je crois que c'est lui les
sept heures du matin en chine 7h30 je
crois un
petit peu bout et arnaquer mais je pense
que c'est parce qu'il ya de plus digeste
mais capable
en tout cas il a l'air en forme hier 2
et feront des cadres déjà dans la
première partie allemand alors là c'est
fou c'est que si je vous donne le coût
de l'ordinateur vous voulez pas
comprendre c'est moi je comprends pas
l'ordinateur il dit avantage blanc tombé
ça ne coule j'aurais jamais et je n'ai
pas honte pourquoi tomber un séminaire
coup
j'imagine que c'est pour anticiper gagné
les trois mais du coup je me dis
j'espère de tout projet 6
ok mais tourbe et un seul coup seul coup
pour prendre avantage juste
incompréhensible
un compliment gestion
je peux dire jusqu'au coude à coude a
alors piqué
j'y suis donc c'est le contre sacrifice
je pouvais être sécurisé et voilà sur
des 4,2 pas avoir de pression sont rois
diagonale après
mes dix messi peut peut-être joué
cavalier p3 s'il veut maintenir les
complications va y aurait les pièces
entre elles avec lynette c'est compliqué
donc à noter que n'a qu'à 25 secondes à
la pendule et elle est bon ça c'est
généralement un enfin c'est rare ouais
ça c'est parce que laquelle il joue très
très vite mais ça montre bien que 10 ne
peut vraiment lui poser des problèmes
sur le mac avec les noirs après un parti
ce serait pas mal
à la reprise brise d'accord donc largué
sa pièce
et il a un bon france 3 qui ne joue pas
mais le fourrage 3 et peut être dans
enfermé dire comment on souffre
toutefois je crois
je peux manger quatre a déjà il va
prendre ici mais y'a rescapés perdu
m'bia ça il a mangé des pires où on
s'arrête un peu complexe mais non mais
j'ai peur que le cavalier f3 puis
j'arrive angers saint caprais et
simulateurs h7 mais il faut voir ce que
laurent blanc un cammas est assez faible
aussi c'est pas évident comme position
il ya de la vie alors être humain les
dates des grands prix fils de famille
oui on a les latins arctique est sorti
search est grave c'est de le retrouver
je dirais que ça commence en février de
mémoire déjà voir
leur tour f4 bien joué je pense par tour
c4 pour manger f4 donc les québécois une
pizza il ya deux pions pour la pièce
mais ça va pas suffire à je pense
pas comment je vois trois ans dès le 3
février besoin d'un axe est d'ailleurs à
quoi une place au grand prix avec deux
places 1 pour le jeu pour le reste des
places 1 et cm 2 places qualificatives
après y'a plus rien et en plus ça va
être bizarre ce que c'est une série de
trois tournois
il va rater l'espace de groupes en fait
donc sinon déjà le groupe dans lequel tu
tends pas être facile lorsqu'on plus au
bois fois
on pas le système est très bizarre assez
détaillés dans l'arctique vont se
renouveler vénérable savoyarde
complètement faire
d'avoir un peu de chance et du tirage au
sort avant pour annuel
ouais alors on espère bien sûr un le cas
de maxime va trouver sa qualif vial via
les grands prix est bas dir scénario
idéal un ce serait que maxime après gars
les candidats que a fait rouge arrive
deuxième et avant une petite finale
enfin un petit match pour le souper à
fond pour le pour la couronne were
destroyed france est elle plus tripant
du coup
alors ok donc on land on a raté la
demande de la partie des gars on a on a
raté que nakamura a gagné autant et
c'est ce que j'avais un petit plus ou
moins rien en fait dans le match ding
aronian et a beaucoup parti qui songe au
temps entre la major du terrain voyance
et dessinant et du coup bas contre
nakamura mal à relancer pas cela parce
qu'elle me récupère pas autant lui lui
pardonne parce qu'ils n'y arrivent pas à
ajuster voilà
qu'après il était fou tu l'as dans la
finale il avait la pièce de moi
c'était le monde à cam ward et mieux
calculer cuit donc il avait gagné cette
bataille tactique on en a perçu en mai
du coeur alors agir tout de suite avec
les blancs pour otegi et ça lui va tout
moto ouais ça lui fait tout au passage
courageuse à cet article atout qui
restait éveillés pour voir le
duo de commentateurs
on veut des joueurs
ouais ouais non mais je pense qu'elle
est tous là pour nous que pour mac à moi
on espère en tout cas la jeunesse maître
de thé propose t
[Rires]
on à une cousine partie
toujours du côté de naga du couquet
sapeurs
pression
donc c'est une position encore une fois
à peu près peu près symétrique avec les
pions avec lui on s'est défoncé changé
on allait le roi qui est symétrique
niveau des pions et cv qui peuvent
changer alors ce fut un des cinq c'est
une pièce qui est très très forte le pur
ans et 4 qu'est ce qu'ils voudront
toujours en embêter embêter les blancs
pour ça prend quand même pas mal de gaz
notamment la case b3 la case d3 et ça
empêche un petit peu un développement
aussi un coût qui peut avoir lieu vos
propositions cinq hommes dames c6 avec
l'idée en fait un jour de
de clouer en fait ce cavalier
rouge à deux c'est super intéressant il
y aura toujours des canadiens 5 et d4
ouais en fait c'est le beau être un pc
de ce serait génial parce que elle
attaquerait le plan b 2 qui de pression
et à case d3 aussi et aucun cavalier
pourrait venir l'attaqué parce que par
exemple dans ces six sur le quai des cas
de camaïeu 5 et donc du coup il ya un
gain de temps choix d'amour après changé
et c'est lui qui doit être ça pourrait
être mieux
alors pas tout je conseille de t'asseoir
par contre même de talent où j'ai pas
comme tu veux que tu restes debout à
ornella pour trois arrêts
iphone solide l'un sur ses appuis je
pense que de vous ça risque de un peu
compliqué
on espère surtout voilà que le match
sera serré quand même que jimmy va
s'accrocher leur agir tout de suite
je pense que tout le monde et pour dean
j'ai l'impression à part peut-être ici
et là dans le chat qui est fan absolu
[Rires]
moi je suis plutôt pour mac est comme je
l'avais dit au début de match j'aime
beaucoup le voir en fait donc
donc du coup je m'amène voir en finale
quand même
mais après ouais toujours supporté
favori c'est se trouvait sur un car on a
déjà vu ça en finale
deux fois
on a dû partir de dakar
alors b3 et joue sur le courageux mais
bout mais c'est derrière j'ai pas
l'impression qu'ils y arrivent parce que
d'un quart bien réagi dans ta kadam
tu pourras peut-être avoir des
certifications match et passer tous les
pions disparaissent
dans l'avion donc la donne des deux
dames b2 - sont écoulés plus logique
hein attention à la fourchette dans la
2stv en c3 mais il s'adapte qu'elle
veuille de 4,6 m un peu visuellement pas
grave à connaître dam des cas tout mais
en blitz j'aurai plus tendance un jeu
dam des deux ici en plus pour avoir le
visa vie avec tour dames 1
les dix kanak a déjà perdu autant saviez
sûrement
sûrement fort je pense quand il perd
autant il n'est pas content ça doit pas
lui arriver ça ben
oui
les horaires à 10 ans ils sont en
fonction d'eux surtout pour les amener à
icare en fait là ils sont pensés pour
bah tant pis
ça lui nico nico the tellers je pense
que je sais qui c'est ah ouais c'est
notre ami à genève où il ya on tient à
jeûner dans
le virage 1 si tu me faisais
du club d'agen si je m en veux pas
et oui ça je n'ai en dire je suis bête
est
ok donc d'âme des uns
il est si un caractère en chine s'était
pas cette raison que je sais qu'il ya 17
ans d'après nos infos n'est peut-être ça
dépend de chine aussi et après je sais
pas parce que mais il est doux en fait
on sait pas où il est ding parce qu'on a
l'impression qu'ils donnent des leçons
motel
et
d'ailleurs pendant le match contre aaron
young il était dans la même chambre et
j'ai obtenu ma chambre de shérif
pourquoi
je crois qu'il dit et puis c'est
vraiment un beau terrain et du coup moi
je me suspecter d'être préparateur d'un
des deux joueurs au chocolat du monde
à dubaï bah je sais pas et m me d'hôtel
il n'y a pas de tournoi je parle ok oui
la droite partir en voyage
non bien sûr mais bon peu tu imagines et
tu vois on mais comment je peux pas du
monde je me retrouve mondial avait-il
alors
c'est pas une question de force je pense
une question de la rue peut être
oui mais après ça soit comme ça
ça peut être aussi une expérience aussi
pour lui de
2,2
d'entraîner un genre comme carl scène tu
as une fois dans ta vie mais après c'est
pas parce que tu es sur gourdon que
forcément 3 2 mais tout est secret car
scène tu vois quelqu'un de cool wave à
répétition dans la position il n'y avait
pas beaucoup de vie
du poids qu'il est loin d'être un objet
ou un mois hyper créatif très
intéressant avec beaucoup d'idées
après en terme
[Musique]
pas question de l'eau près de 700
chevaux mais année
mais il est encore un peu instable
de brefs et part pour le niveau de jeu
par 2008 tu as genre genre le jour où
doit fuir à une série le sans-parti sans
défaite comme l'avait fait le ding je
pense qu'on est quand même pas encore
moi j'aime beaucoup du beauf un je
t'aime beaucoup y est mais bon il n'est
pas stable et sûr on sera amené à l'est
pas parce que je pense pas non plus
réagi hier d'ailleurs je dois avoir juré
25 ans
je dirais un peu père de 2,18 comme ça
et du coup bah c'est un petit peu tard
je pense enfin généralement à 25 ans tu
as déjà tellement car c'est ni la place
de 1800 kg à
19 ans ouais si je me trompe pas et est
bon feu rouge a perdu 18 ans
maxime et là il
2007 70 par la has et jalousie je pense
que là il a quand même pas mal de retard
sur sur le genre généralement après ça
veut rien dire un il peut très bien
avoir son gros coup de boost
bon
ça semble assez improbable
alors ils ont rejoué dont j'ai pas fait
trop attention aux propos mais ça
ressemble beaucoup à pouvoir partir
ouais bah je crois que c'est à peu près
la même position avec aiguillages cinq
inscriptions un petit peu il ya eu la
chaîne des appartements
bon c'est pas un mauvais choix pour ding
même s'il avait perdu ce n'était pas du
tout lié à l'ouverture jusque dans les
complications tactique s'est un peu
égaré quoi il a de nouveau après huit
positions très très solide avec les
noirs on va voir s'ils gèrent mieux le
bio
il a vu une prime plus de talent mais en
tout cas bon c'est comme une bonne
nouvelle de voir qu'ils égalisent à
chaque fois avec les noirs est
donc bon d'un point saint-élie de match
tu vois si philippe noguère chaque fois
à voir
si possible donc un village cinq banques
l'an 70 ans comme fou ici
et oui les commentaires dans le chat la
quinzaine la fois il a fait le speech
est il l'a fait deux fois croit quand il
était en finale contre dung quât il
l'avait
largement dominée il n'y a pas une bâche
et l'autre année il avait perdu parce
que l'an dernier puisque pas de liste
contre maxime en demi finale car à cette
superbe performance de maxime et du coup
maxime avait ensuite perdu contre accord
final aux mineurs voici qu'aujourd'hui
re du monde oublie pas sur internet qui
vont avoir lieu d'ailleurs là à noël
avoir soumis avec un cette cellule dans
le patron c'est pas dans les carnets
qu'elle rêve d'avoir un premier titre
c'est un excellent passeur surtout sur
internet m pour l'instant il est quand
même derrière
maintenant ils n'ont pas le même
palmarès camin
donc pas d'un palmarès et
car dans sa bête noire de naka je sois
d'accord je pense pas y être une forme
de complexe aussi hein parce que même en
classique c'est très très mal contre
15,7 d'accord très mauvais score ouais
ouais bon aprilia bêtement et bête noire
mes poils pour moi il a faim il ay la
censure comprendre que
ouais ben par rapport au moyen par
exemple à d'autres joueurs du top alors
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai mais il perd
beaucoup plus de particules qu'un autre
joueur de son éloquence et
tu sens que barbie quand tu joues comme
akalé blanc draka treize heureux de
faire ça nul avec les blancs
voient là et d'ailleurs est d'ailleurs à
un moment donné il me semble que d'un
cas il avait il avait annoncé que
c'était le seul joueur qui pouvait
battre carlson en match j'appelle à du
monde là et est à ce moment là je crois
qu'il perdait il perd 2 0 je crois c'est
le score c'était 11 0 il y avait en eux
des nuls a bien sûr il y avait plein de
nul mais il y avait 11 victoires pour 40
cède 0 pour nous pour dakar et n'a qu'à
avec le culot de dire c'était le seul
match sérieux
mois à peu près mais bon quand tu perds
marc 0 juste
juste vos
scores et violent et bon juste
ils étaient contents quand il m'a fait
plaisir
alors ça j'aime bien ce couple 6
il va sûrement
c'était le cavalier à revenir en f3 faut
quand même calculé à présent quatre tout
tu peux gagner un pion alors tu vas
perdre à trois derrière après yassa ans
la pollution partir en cacahuète
pas ce qui s'est vraiment
régalé trop enfouies f5 maintenant du
coin c'était l'idée je pense à ce
qu'auraient l'époque le fou ici là ces
découvertes il laisse la découverte
qu'elle va les prendre et 3 je pense que
ça marchera jamais on perd cannes deux
pièces pour tours pions et c'est
vraiment par moments la position on
préfère garder la grèce
drôle de gueule cette tour au sénat
ouais c'est parce qu'il veut en faire
parce que c'est vrai que c'est assez
bizarre
et sa horde à manger mettre un torrent
c5 et après essayer de changer des
pièces mesure kanak d2 chebeya c'est
trop noir tandis que va choisir d'ici
mai pour les noirs ont leurs codes on va
en voir fiche la différence d'activité
jeudi joue sur plus de ronchères qui
jettent alors moi je n'ai bien
évidemment je sais pas si c'est bon du
tout givet le coup eu cinq en fait
l'idée c'est de jouer contre le
vis-à-vis torero dames et ouvrir la
pollution la tourelle est mal placé la
dernière blague c'est sa valeur
intéressante c'est possible en attendant
proposait pas peut-être que 5 et plus
possible
et oui c'est ça neopost est le seul dans
le top niveau avoir un score positif
contre un quart en scène mais du coup en
gagnant ses trois parties en quatre
parties
il est revenu à hauteur carson
il n'a plus aucun à sa phase négative
mais je crois qu'en plus le parti qu'il
a été rendu à l'époque c'était d'être
actif ici les jeunes n'ont pas inventé
le championnat du monde des moins de 12
ans
on fait ça ça compte pas trop long mais
s'ils
aboient didier houi là qui est tu peux
dire ça groupe mais excusez moi
l'allemagne on a 30 ans je continue ce
point du mans quand on avait 12 ans
accompagnés
et dingman on dit qu'il n'est pas
qualifié pour l'instant il va nous
sépare il est qualifié pour les grands
prix nous pensent qu'il est allé faire
les grands prix qui sont donc le
dernière dernier moyen d'espérer scania
devra batailler avec les autres pour
gagner deux places
ok donc mac à droite car ce qui fait la
qualité pour éléments gestion des 5
j'aime bien ce qu'il a fait
j'aime beaucoup ce qu'il a fait même
parce que le plus d'aisance et qu'elle
maintient qu'important imposition
jackass 2 400 cavaliers actuellement un
trou qui provient en c3 en pratique ça a
l'air pas mal pour les blancs il ya deux
fous est un pion et à distance
et le roi qui peut être impeccable sur
15 mois infligée le fou qui veut
toujours revenir h4 belle réaction bon
moment même sur glace blanche ouais ben
généralement tout sur la case de
couleurs que la personne n'a pas donc là
les devants à [ __ ] case blanche donc
logiquement le jeu des blancs doit se
faire sur case blanche avait cavalcade
dams et 4 par exemple ça peut être des
idées mais on en fait se foutent un peu
misérable en scène joue mal mais m ces
trois tendances c'est pour ça que
je parlais des cases - là mais mais
généralement on va essayer de plutôt
jouer sur la case de couleur que le lag
la femme n'a pas
je suis ouf a fait avec ses moyens sont
toujours
les hommes argentine les gars
oui il est chez moi il est il est 20
heures
pile mais bon
moi je suis bien en fait je crois qu'ils
ont vu du match pour tout ce qu ils sont
libres actionnement faut pas que ce soit
trop tard pour stouff quand même les
gars étaient fatigués
khanafou de dicastère du matin c'est
stouff qui quand quoi
alors tu en dises et demi je le vois on
ne voit pas du tout performer au
prochain candidat une fois plus c'est
rouler mais on sait qu'il ya deux ans
les écarts lensois va réagir soit il va
mettre du temps
après dépôt de ce qu'il a annoncé là il
avait quand même vachement travailler
j'ai jamais autant travaillé de sa vie
bon c'est des trucs qui peuvent compter
on le voit
est temps enfin tu as quand même
1 un an à voir les candidats
et
oui on savait réguliers dont qu'il a et
des bas mais ce qui est bien c'est que
le tournoi se joue dans plus d'un an et
il attend de ce renard un bob barker
ouais parce que sinon c'est un job en
fait
en fait lui c'est un joueur qui dit
beaucoup moi je me reconnais beaucoup
dans son style parce que peut-être un
taux pareil niveau de think that she là
mais du coup là le tente de se remettre
un petit peu d'oublier de faire autre
chose donc du coup
je pense que ça veut rien dire je pense
que il capable de faire un très bon
tournoi comme un mauvais mais ce ne sera
pas forcément fin je pense qu'il y aura
pas de problème par rapport à ce qu'il a
fait là
on voit qu'il est très mal de temps
encore il voit une seconde 11 secondes
pour pour ding 48 pour n'a qu'à une
enquête garde des pièces il fait red
spéciale il place ses pièces il va
jusqu'à value added to b 3 il va tourner
avec deux voix là il va il va le
tranquillement donc il faut b 3 à 4 ou
un truc comme ça bien géré ce gredin
qaeda 15%
il exagère peut-être mais ouais tu
exagère un peu de chance que j'ai
l'impression hammam et s'immisce n'est
trop mal autant il ne s'est pas joué sur
ça
ouais
ouais tu n'as qu'à y va poser des
problèmes de peau de banane un jetpack y
va il a balancé il va pas
il va pas attendre
trois dames bien
ok watson restait que 9 secondes depuis
un petit moment villa pas si mal conçus
aux fourches attendait 6 ouais pour
certains ce que leurs cadets c'est
surtout celui qui a du coup il ya venus
exprès et lui le magnat en trois
ans
l'ami roger de l'homme
et le roi sur les cases blanches qui
conduisent qu'à se brancher important
simple ce concept est légal quand vous
avez il attend
quand vous avez la paire de fouet que
versailles la caf ou essaient de jouer
sur la couleur que l'autre n'a pas en
fait vous êtes dominant la paire
soucasse blanche qui met tout le monde
que les autres cavaliers en c4 bon on
n'a peut-être pas mais généralement nous
qu'à se venger après c'est pas facile
c'est la position que quelqu'un un tacle
à un mea éléments jupes sont achetés
et s'ajuste niveau acceptable
je pense à vue
dont kilomètres à peine qu'est donc là
d'un bouge
2,5 2,4 ça commence à venir pour
appliquer la russie ce qui arrive au
moins 10 mettant des choses mais j'ai
peur que la l'ouverture de la position
elle va sourire au bout d'un projet 6 ça
commençait bien peut-être cavaliers de 5
à tour g1 qui va arriver tour g1 qui a
valu au sein que ça va faire très très
mal il ya foule 5 qui veut arriver au
site outre un jour à la cera dans tous
les sens
des gestes
prise prise voilà c'est fini je pense
au dernier set
mais c'était marrant je crois pas
d'emprunt je croyais bien vous aussi
ceux ci il va dans la roya ses leçons et
dim qui est très content
petit sourire de ding le macaque est
mort de rire et kyocera
à y perdre en fait je pense je guéris il
a été puni pour pour le beau jeu hein
mais ouais donc d'un premier set il
voulait récupérer fine fourchette y
récupérer la tour en prenant une dame
promotion mais l'objet d'un prêt je
crois qu'ils aient qu'ils aiment at my
way
95 pour
tous
oui donc à égalité 1-1 au bout d'une
demi heure de jeu dont un tiers du temps
réglementaire ans inclusivement on est à
égalité alors tout à l'heure en off ça
mais qui m'a dit que tu pensais que ding
partirait avec un avantage après cinq
messieurs
je pronostique à quel point il est allé
gagner sur 2 5 pouces jeunes parce que
j'espérais
seule chance j'ai envie de dire s'ils
veulent faire dans le match il faudrait
qu'ils qui gagne cette portion parce que
bah je pense plus accélère jusqu'à
calais favoriser
d'abord parce qu'après c'est vrai que
aux échecs pur quand même digne et
sensée être plus forts et 5 plus une
quinte à temps de réfléchir talent tant
de voilà
donc
je pense pas que 10 ne soit vraiment en
dessous dans cette cadence par contre
tout ce qui est rare que ce n'est plus
une maille grise n'a rien
je pense qu à kariat qui n est pas je
vais sérieusement moi je pense que vous
il va se préparer à fou
alors alors juste je réveille c'est
votre jour mais je crois que ouest il ya
deux jours chez excédent monde dans mon
lit et par conséquent je la félicite
santoro lis avec moi c'est les fans de
sommeil thi hoa et quand j'ai insomnies
que j'arrive pas dans un milieu
targeting sa carrière
je me suis dit en fait c'était après la
bourse de 400 eu à qui j'aurais pas et
j'ai du parti j'imagine le match kayak
in radjabov championnat du monde moi je
me pends
non mais en fait ça va faire que des
nuls mammifères ils vont ils vont faire
4e de cette insupportable
mais en fait ils vont faire toujours la
même espagnol avec d'un premier cadavre
cats est un nul là bas
mais en fait
il a beaucoup d'expérience il est très
bon sur la pression mais saches d'accord
et moi je pense car akin les favoris sur
eux d'abord par exemple pour moi c'est
évident mais je veux dire
c'est vraiment
[Musique]
l'anpaa à bramois
de base j'aime pas mais alors depuis les
la sphère du golfe à khanaqinne s'il
peut perdre vous verrez un souffle
content non mais c'est vrai que là c'est
insupportable enfin je veux dire c'est
quoi le problème de d'entraîner enfin je
veux dire ça
[Musique]
non mais pas là en train de en train de
préparer c'est par m6 compte norvège
quoi
enfin cesser un jour contre un joueur tu
as enfin juste enfin bon chacun son
opinion moi je ne peux pas mais juste
je trouve ça dégueulasse c'est stupide
qu'il ya un peu bas car il est inégal à
un peu plus tôt après tu peux voir si
dans un genre
d'art j'ai vu un truc qui m'a bien fait
rire tout à l'heure sur le mur de romain
edouard une comparaison
sur un même si c'est
genre tel talent mais qui est il est en
couple avec sa meuf donc il tient la
main il se retourne ce qui ira vers des
laudes neuf donc ce même et qui est
enfin ce même chambre qui est qui est
très connu et en fait du coup il y avait
marqué je crois qu'il avait dit poutine
khanaqinne est double bon ben il faut
aller voir son fils pour ceux qui sont
amis avec les mêmes par contre ça se
raconte très mal mais malheureusement
parce qu'il faut l'image il faut l'image
mais mais ça va bien ça ira et à
kara qui ne m'a jamais trop aimé de base
c'est pas un joueur qui m'a juste m'a
toujours non mais oh no h accès
ont déjà que c'est vraiment un très très
bon joueur en fait il est très très bon
en défense très bons en contres et c'est
un joueur qui a toujours été au top
niveau hyper régulier
bah ouais il a mené dans le match s'est
même porté c'est le seul qui a mené
contre erstein
bas à nantes a ouvert le score mais
derrière
ça va
voilà soulagés 7 cette femme c'est quoi
le le voit ça met la pression sur la
fibre cantons prendre le
match par le jeu il parie de qui vous
parlez de 15,7 rouge à
moi je pense pas
enfin le terran fait qu'il a dit dans
cette carte scène il a besoin d'avoir de
nouveaux objectifs
ils gagnent pas du moins sûr qu'il le
joue bon il ya eu des matchs genre
contre carbonne a par exemple il n'y a
pas eu de gain
bon ça
ça coûte cher 1 de préparation c'est pas
du tout une histoire d'argent non mais
l'idée en fait il ya beaucoup beaucoup
enfin j'avais lu un truc
bon ok mais c'est pas un plein d'argent
il élit les richissimes d'axa mais en
fait surtout tu as le toute l'énergie
que tu passes à préparer un match
championnat du monde est donc déjà c'est
la première chose et puis
et puis carsen bon enfin ces deux du
absolue je vois pas ce qui peut le
battre au match et je pense qu'elle j'ai
besoin d'objectifs quoi gens là on
disait que jean-luc il a dit qu'il
voulait parce que 1900 et l'eau
donc ça c'est intéressant ça double ce
mélo ses fils a dit que cela lui
semblait de nouveau joie parce que
jusque là ça lui parle c'est vraiment
impossible il ya vu que la grille n est
point gaza non
mais en fait en fait il est positif il
ay là il a dit qu'il pensait pas
vraiment parce qu'il pensait que c'est
inatteignable mais maintenant ils
aimeraient se fixer de nouveaux
objectifs
et je pense que c'est intéressant parce
que là je peux a dit on savait que
pour l'instant battu à l'aller bon
compte n'y est pas il ya pas eu de match
et
non je pense qu'il a plus besoin
après je pense qu'il va voir si jamais
on n'a vu rosa qui vient et qui passera
de 56 kg en peluche pas du monde on
arrive assure t on au quai bontron va à
mon avis par exemple c'était digne de
gagner les candidats ça pouvait
signifier m cependant il y avait envie
de jouer contre 1,1 et pau ou bien
quelqu'un qui a déjà joué ou qui les
stimulent - foire mais je pense que
10000 pourrait aussi vrai ding ding des
fio peut-être guéroult aussi les deux
soeurs voilà papa routine
après c'est surtout car match sur
couvert du monde va être sa demande en
tout comme tu l'as dit énormément de
sacrifices de préparation bien l'aspect
financier c'est juste que bah voilà
pendant c'est que pendant un an il a
passé à tous ces entraînements là-dessus
quoi
les listings et chargez pas aussi
excitant
alors qu'un one a aussi notamment la non
je pense pas vu qu'il a déjà joué un
match plus adjoint il ya eu 12 hull bon
je pense pas que
que non
mais je vois mes h voilà je pense pas
que ce soit ce qui peut le faire à mon
trip et et mvl d'un bel c'est une mêmes
ressorts que des po1 c'est 7 53 d'hommes
combats dans le centre maxime c'était
encore malheureusement jamais qualifiée
pour les candidats déjà que l'angle de
repêcher volume moi
mais je pense que carte celle d'un
maxime dépendance ou la joie
extraordinaire grâce à elle il doit
s'estimer vraiment un cran au dessus et
il pense que
peut-être oui c'est pas suffisamment
motivant parce qu'il sait qu'il est plus
fort en fait à mon avis ça ici c'est je
suis plus fort qui on regarde on va il
ya 18 ans est en train d'exploser alaya
viendrait peut-être challenge pour son
négoce y
aura bien sûr les gens se respectent à
haut niveau un magnus respecte maxime
mais c'est vrai que vous il pense que si
à malte contre maxime basse passa sous
que je pense carrément envie de voir un
vrai challenge fois donc il attend la
relève firoud ou alors un joueur très
fort très solide comme dix minutes après
c'est votre avis y un mais on sait pas
ce qu'il pense qu'arsène on a peut être
un c4 interprétation de ces déclarations
voilà
après il a quand même pu essayer de
battre le record de renault 3 2 qu'ils
s'étaient lascars qui a été cette fois
ci ouais et
voici une autre époque aussi donc c'est
difficile oui oui bon bah et moi par
rapport à l'histoire les records tout ça
ça peut être sympa aussi mais bon après
je comprends que mes plus rien à prouver
là tu vois et puis on râle il a déclaré
ça maintenant
h le temps d'évoluer
encore une fois c'est au match il aura
lieu dans deux ans donc on a le temps de
voir un petit peu ce que donnent les
joueurs qui arrivent le nouveau joueur
parce que bien sûr on parle de fille
rosa comme on peut parler de beaucoup
d'autres joueurs mais on peut aussi
parler de joueurs donc la relève était
le petit russe lacombe et s'appelle
jacques qui a battu car c'est d'ailleurs
à ce qu'elle aime comme si bien qu'au
par exemple
[Musique]
est largement
mais enfin ils ont ils ont 17 buts en 27
30 par là des sites et qu on arrêterait
auprès des classes lorsqu'on vous devez
blesse la pause c'est la pause nous
avoir dit à lui et
doublettes formées de bois filets
dont on n'a pas tout à l'heure
il est derrière nous pas comparer à -cp
une qu il a dix ans
+19 exagéré non mais il a plus vieux
mais c'est pas la même génération ils
je pense que c'est les patrons objets
petits pas
je pense pas que kiki qui
joue pour être champion du monde
madou bof il a 25 ans
et gsm n'est qu'au
19 8e 6 ans d'écart bon c'est pas
tu vois tu vois quand même que
donc ce n'est pas du genre à la même
comment fatou réclame la pub
et ans et on va devant lens la pub
d'ailleurs parce qu'on n'a pas qu'on ne
l'a pas fait la semaine dernière pas
trop en quasiment et il faut quand même
que vous ayez d'aptus commun donc c'est
pas la pub la pub pub de twitch là c'est
la pub pièces comme avec les les bref
les abonnements abonnements etc bon du
coup les gars on vous dit da a tout de
suite dans trois quatre et huit ans je
pense qu'on va revenir et donc ne vous
endormez pas ce qu'elle veut c'est que
tard chez vous mais
met en avant minuit cas ça va encore ça
va encore aller à tout de suite on se
retrouve toutes pièces
[Musique]
et nous sommes revenus les joueurs vont
reprendre
le match je pense donc on est à 2 2
après la pause donc il ya eu deux
matches nuls et deux victoires de chaque
côté
[Musique]
la ville n'a pas encore sifflé le la
reprise du mode je pense qu'il un
sifflet des arbitres je pense qu'il a un
sifflet par contre peu après sa vie
assez bon je te voyais plutôt camerata
camarades bug à meyrals s'enlève des
fois c'est bizarre
qui pas d'explication
non plus là bas on te voit nick est
alors de partout il ya
trois ans mais ça c est l abri dorment à
qu'ils ont et qu'ils ont eue mairie ok
mais mais là mais je pense que il pas de
raison que nakache change et les joues
autre chose préval et f3
combien de personnes sont endormis
pendant la pub combien de meurtres dans
cette prime
il a encore pas trop tard encore les
quais munyemana là je pense que c'est un
accord on chaque coup on prend un risque
supérieur oui malheureusement oui
chaque pause on prend un on prend le
risque
de vos parties et des gens donc le match
dure environ trois heures trois heures
et demie
donc le match de rupture du gouvernent
vers 2h30 du matin
miel donc amplement car trois jours
ouais t'as lieu de jeunes gens venus
saluer jo de jeu bonsoir à toi merci de
nous accompagner dans ce stream
nocturnes
et les joueurs vous font du bien si on
me sens la caméra l
arbitre siffle il a un vrai sifflet
[Rires]
du café en intraveineuse
la friture
ça lui plaisait
alors dans sa a repris donc là c'est un
récit est tout à l'heure il avait joué
des quatre voilà
donc prise car à l'époque à rallier ses
six adjoints k5 ok ça c'est intéressant
et on a eu ce type de position bah je
croise dans la partie nac dans le match
de la can contre qui j'ai joué tous
précédent
ighirri j'avais la con qui rit j'avais
vu des l'avait déjà vu des histoires
tueur de ce style country guyane
la veille il est facile un contrat que
j'ai
l'enjeu c'est de l'argent alors j'essaie
de devenir le champion du speech s 2021
vous n'êtes pas la moitié d'un
ok jazz vers d'honneur pour le futur
vainqueur on n'a qu'à qu'il ya déjà
trois
racailles ou deux
ils veulent collectionner les titres là
une place en finale pour retrouver des
sceaux mais sinon y'a pas mal d'argent à
la gag aussi être que cela motive encore
plus les joueurs que
peuvent avoir leur nom au palmarès et
une énorme enjeu non non je
pars si créer un speech est je pense que
les joueurs
vont devenir les champions du speed
chaise et le script shell de bronze sur
les prix les prix que les évadés et là
on peut la regarder par contre ouais là
vous l'avez vous l'avez sur le stream
ouais alors à quand une allait marquer
dix mille dollars pour le pour le
gagnant et 10000 $ / le pourcentage de
gains donc c'est encore pas clair c'est
donc et demi finales 6 6 milles pour le
gagnant de la semaine de la demi finale
avec simili les externes au final ça
fait un petit pactole qu'on accumule est
donc là je sais pas comment ça peut être
de visu mais peut-être
je pense une
trentaine de l'art un
vainqueur et un
peu près
l'autre demie a déjà été jouée c'est so
so qui est qualifié pour la finale qui a
battu notre ami indien ni al sarine 16
ans ou dix sept ans que je me trompe
disent aller et il a gagné 2 sur le
score de 15 à 14 c'est très sain tu as
beau match yes on espère avoir autant de
suspense
pour l'instant on est homo n'est pas
loin de la vérité
pour l'instant on n'est pas malheureux
avec 2,2 dans ce début de match
well as bien il élite et darche mans il
avait gagné
là comme ça me l'a dit la veille il
avait gagné le serbe le smi jazzy
juniors donc moins de 20 ans et donc
l'elecam arriver en demi-finale du speed
cesse
bah tout confondu et il a aidé une
oeuvre notamment gris tchouk duda c'est
quand même c'est quand même pas rien il
a éliminé rapporte pas de pardon ce
climat oui mais les deux joueurs se
ressemblent pour moi j'ai souvent je
vais
mais bon ils ont un style similaire on a
l'impression et
ayant un temps qui n'est pas pourquoi
beaucoup dans le temps dans les tournois
de haut niveau malheureusement
est alors alireza elle il aurait sa
place dans le tableau principal
il est numéro deux mondial est
d'ailleurs il devait jouer il était
inscrit et comme on a parié en début de
stream finalement au dernier moment
après sa qualification pour les
candidats il a changé d'avis la dct pas
partie il avait été remplacé par rapport
mais sinon suffire où j'avais joué ça
aurait été le favori derrière nike sur
le pape hier
derrière et encore
sur internet normalement il faut voir
avec sow parce que souhaitait me perds
du talent oui et l'autre cas il aura
cette arme à un clermont et des joueurs
les plus dangereux clairement il a fait
partie des baux favori a vu lui et don
pur jus de brioches dick à 16,1 en inde
oui bien sûr mais il faut voir quand
même que
ça arrive il a un sponsor
enfin en fait à 16 ans enfin il un
sponsor mais peut-être même plusieurs je
t'ai pas et donc mon île et pas
malheureux non plus hein c'est pas
l'indien qui farias normal tôt samedi
donc puis les suivaient nous tiennent
ils à hilla la vie y est pas il n'est
pas à plaindre
mais après bien sûr d'où vient-il cat
est content comme ça c'est clair
combien de joueurs vifs des échecs dans
le monde a beaucoup quand même mais
enfin là ok comparé à d'autres foires
pas énorme je pense ça dépend de pas
déjà tu peux vivre le juge du jeu de tes
gains en tournois où vivront
ces sympathiques chez switcher à ce que
tu fais plein de choses en fait pas
sentir gagner des tournois et ne pouvait
servir je passe d'être quelques-uns des
arbitres
[Musique]
mais en tant que joueur vraiment jouer
et des médias libyens pour le cours en
france sur des gens qui vivent très très
bien des échoppes moi je pense qu'on a
trois
bas annuel
est d'environ jasmin et bien
oui mais mais en tant que joueur de
montbéliard avant fin mai n'a plus d'un
an plus tôt mais bon bah du coup en tant
que joueur je pense qu'on a on a
vraiment que les deux 2 ans donc on n'a
que furent la maxime bac et bien sûr aux
civils ouais mais rennes joue plus en
fait la ligne artnet la boutique à la
faille tchèque il fait un peu autre
chose mais mais après tu as d'autres
genres qui
qui vivent de ça en fait en france mais
bon un degré moins un mois des joueurs
qui ont de 1550 mais ici ça
ils font voir il voulut tournoi il
entraîne et font un petit peu tout et
donne des cours bien chars après voilà
c'est pas c'est pas le top top top
niveau mais il arrive à vivre
correctement mais par contre je pense
que
généralement si t'as pas de 1550 euros
minimum
c'est un peu difficile de vivre en tant
que joueur parce que ben a suivi par
bien en tant que joueur on galère des
gains c'est juste dans les domaines de
l'état noir à pied de compliqué surtout
marne à bula pendant la période de kobe
est justement l'égalisation forcément
des noirs album tournoi là ça a été très
dur pour beaucoup de joueurs dans
l'entre-deux 1500 et 2650 parce qu'il ya
du travail en est au chômage technique
va s'exercer compliqué
c'est compliqué
la team de naka ménaka il l'apanage
martin
jarrie mais pas il n'a pas d'entraîneur
pas a priori non mais quand ils jouent
plus de chacun il joue plus compétition
enfin une idée là il fait les mécontents
de jeu le temps sur internet de stream
etc mais maintenant il est plus très
sérieux enfin entre est il le plus grand
du monde ça il a compris que ça
dans ce trailer d'un car c'est plus un
joueur c'est ça du coup il a plus de
la plus de
ils appelent entraîneur rennes a eu à
l'époque a probablement été suivie mais
bon il nous qu'est ce qu'on fait bats
toi si toi sa me que tu fais dans ma vie
à manger travail pour pièces comme
justement tu vois je donne des cours
aussi les portes 16 comme j'écris
principalement je me suis rien du raid
kevin leur notera on va commencer le
deuxième
travail est al qaïda lui aussi grâce aux
échecs mais on touche là à plein de
choses dans ce milieu a pas de méga
tournoi en tout cas c'est sûr c'est bon
ça serait compliqué
une heure plus vous quasiment plus de
choc de samedi bah non je voulais juste
par équipe avec le combiné compliqué
donc le deuxième livre il sera un
recueil de partie pédagogique me sera
plus poussé que le premier qui était
quand même pour les débutants du joueur
là la fourchette sera plus 1200 1800 par
exemple donc ce sera des belles parties
les pour marquer l'histoire des échecs
mais surtout qui sont intéressantes à
analyser a expliqué
que vous compreniez le plus de choses
possibles en termes de prise des
décisions de stratégie
tout ce qui peut faire progresser quoi
toi steve du coup bah moi j'étais
entraîneur pendant de nombreuses années
club de cannes échecs
est là depuis septembre j'ai arrêté
j'arrête mon activité parce que je
voulais me lancer en maître sur internet
je trouve que c'est plus intéressant
pour moi pour plusieurs
la
raison est la première ce que balla
maintenant je suis à l'étranger je peux
voyager parce que je travaille en fait
pour mon compte et par internet du coup
c'est quand même plus simple pour moi de
pouvoir faire ça et puis après que le
boom des échecs aussi sur internet avec
les stream avec tout ça et bien il est
vrai que maintenant je pense que c'est
intéressant de travailler sur internet
donc je donne des cours d'échecs en fait
donc par skype et je suis aussi streamer
donc pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
d'ailleurs je sais ce que tu peux me
faire le petit saut s'amuse
à te connais pas les petits sauts oui
c'est une collard c'est une commande que
tu peux faire quand ils les modes
et moi en fait je peux pas me le faire à
moi même
trop de la cmu rsa je suis mode mais
voila voila commandes et un patron du
jeu non non c'est que c'est que le motif
doivent le faire donc ça peut le faire
puisque moi je peux pas me le faire à
moins d'un an fait ce que j'avais essayé
de faire quand j'étais avec kevin
terrieux quand j'avais commenté jeudi la
pub pour lui moi je pouvais pas le faire
voilà merci service donc pour ceux qui
ne connaissent pas la chaîne de souffre
allez la voir elle est vraiment cool
et donc là j'ai un petit soucis
actuellement un pur stream 1
je pense qu'il voulait voter ou pas mais
en fait depuis justin sur caisse comme
pour les speechs s eh bien j'ai un petit
souci c'est que je
pourrai dire à me connecter via obs et
et ben j'ai besoin d'un mot de passe kim
est envoyé par sms et comme mon numéro
français ne marche plus et ben je ne
peux pas
envoyer le mot de passe demandé j'ai
changé de numéro de téléphone tout
s'accéléra mais tous ne le prend pas
donc pour l'instant je suis un petit peu
en r&d et tous nos rêves ne me répond
pas non plus aux mails que j'envoie donc
c'est un peu compliqué mais très très
bientôt je reviendrai l'espère ce week
end je vais vraiment faire ça c'est de
trouver une solution à ce problème parce
que je n'aime pas normal ça fait plus
d'une semaine que je ne peux pas que je
ne peux pas stream sur ma page
c'est ça 50 à saint quentin là tu
remarqueras que j'ai quand même donné
les 520 par par fair play quand même
parce qu'on avait parié 500 avec ce
robert malley cela une seule battles et
je déclare forfait parce que je devrais
pas me connecter et et j'ai quand même
offert les cinq soldes parce que j'ai
quand même pas lu par forfait je
trouvais ça honnête de ma part
c'est un cas qui grimacent là où la wii
bas sur ma vie a
dit me sentirai la digue naturelle dans
votre et et baca
qui donne encore des cours alors georges
alors je donne des cours encore
actuellement effectivement alors sur mon
switch et la commande cours
malheureusement la course en cascade ne
marche pas donc si vous voulez me parler
tout simplement les gens vous avez vous
avez accès mon compte
à mon compte caisse comme dirait là
dessus c'est très bien
et ainsi des comptes ou des sous ou wes
et oui comment s'appelle s'appelle tu
joues c'est s'est pas vraiment de
l'argent c'est légitime des noms des dix
ans arrivé du cat à l'époque c'était
l'âme des ouais mais là c'est différent
ce cd livres
puisque c'est exactement comme truc j'ai
des potes qui
qui le font à face où cette barre et
ne s'est pas trop d'options disponibles
autriche
mais en fait apparemment c'est un truc
qui reliait ton facebook à toutes les
eaux de ce tueur et du combat qui était
cette femme
mais
je sais pas trop ce que ça vaut
mais avoir en tout cas l'interface elle
est dégueulasse et cim
gabon avait vraiment à
chier mais bon après
je crois que c'est pour les crypto
monnaies antiques comme ça je crois que
tout ça en fait
mais tu peux tu peux déposer de l'argent
que je crois pour avoir plusieurs
échiquiers et après tu dois jouer je
crois un peu tous les jours et en fait à
chaque fois que tu gagnes parti bah tu
gagnes
un truc des crypto et
edward tu sais pas compte qu'ils jouent
et c'est que et c'est que c'est qu'en
dix minutes face à trévise art contre
répondent oui verve à la truite façon
qui a dû fermer
tiens tiens alors moi j'ai travaillé
pendant pendant six ans que obtenir un
et pendant cinq ans au club de club de
cannes donc à savoir que cannes c'est
vraiment le grand club ben on va dire en
france mais tu es un des meilleurs clubs
formateurs voire peut-être le numéro un
donc moi je t'ai le numéro deux en tant
qu'entraîneur donc c'est pas moi qui
forme est également au tout départ moi
je les prix une fois qu'ils savaient
déjà bien jouer et donc moi j'ai
entraîné sur quatre ans donc j'avais
régulièrement les mains et nos élèves
donc parmi ceux qui performait toute la
france dont j'avais à nous battre donc
la tipp sur de bill goodship kotick qui
connaissent voit qu'elle a fait 3e au
championnat de france de la dernière
année et cette année malheureusement qui
n'y étaient pas mal enfin podium et et
j'entraînais aussi donc un autre charge
de tairai le nom qui avait fait aussi un
podium en poussins
je tairai le nom pour des questions
bref je me comprend
et
donc actuellement je travaille aussi
avec un avec un autre joueur qui pour le
coup j'ai appris à bouger des pièces il
ya très peu de temps fayyad être trois
ans et qui maintenant après 18 cents
lots en pupilles première année
est donc mort pas de nom
pas de nom
et donc j'ai pas formé de grandes stars
pour l'instant mais
mais j'ai quand même mon pied pas de
marée ce tranquille on va dire
est-ce que je connais pas l'avenir
l'acide bien cherche des candidats bien
gelée connu j'ai commis parce que
j'avais le tanit toute ma vie et qu'il
est tk noir je suis moi je te revient au
club de cannes une fois qu'ils étaient
partis en fait donc ne pas croiser on
voudra travailler ensemble jeannot je
les connais je le connais encore
yes fatou exactement dans sa part des
histoires suisse parle
pas tout vous dire ici
que j'aime bien et noirs ici voyez la
part de frôler blanc mais j'aime bien en
fait le fait que le cavalier soit ici
j'ai pu y avoir des petites parle et on
pensait n'être l'appel même parraine la
partie d'avant mais ça a fait une lui
tout change est symétrique s'est rien
passé les séries depuis la cabine
beaucoup de positions
assez symétrique voit encore une ici
même si elle a perdu fou mais bon c'est
pas à djoko bonito
pour la petite finale pour ce cadre que
les blues d'un petit peu mieux dans la
paire de fous là le fond 1,5 c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour les blancs je pense
ouais parce que du coup la torture en
trio clouage problème alors pour
répondre à coup le coyote
[Musique]
safar des histoires si je parle des six
pas envie de mais en gros il ya eu des
problèmes
une suggestion de la défense il va
bientôt connaître vient se jeter tête
quand la fille non pas du tout
absolument pas passé loin c'était pas
pour cette histoire là
quant à cette non je veux dire
ce que je veux dire c'est que c'était
pas du tout pour ça non c'était un gamin
création du club accueille des problèmes
à un mini lapsus quand même
pas cette fois mais arrêter quoi
non mais moi je regarde où vous fait
dire ce que je n'ai pas dit
[Rires]
le malaise
alors pour répondre à coup le coyote
parce que je me suis un peu garrel avec
quatre côtes de sa vie
il est encore donc il encore dans le
monde des échecs je crois un petit peu
mais il est plutôt club de cannes échecs
il ya eu des petits problèmes
voilà il ya eu des problèmes ils
parvenus non il ne viendra pas
ok donc b4 ça empêche les cadres des
blancs
cette finition et petric imagine même le
monde de choses qu'on pourra commencer
cette position alors en vrai ce sens
sans blague moi j'aime bien les noirs
par situe en fait j'ai la colonne main
que je veux que je peux prendre puisque
les plantes peuvent pas la grâce aux
cavaliers ici ouais mais ce qu'à l'aller
où est la défense du tube et katia un
petit pour l'instant c'est un problème
effectivement j'aurais du mal à attirer
mon cavalier passe pirates toujours
champion en l'air mais ce pion peut
aussi être faibles alors attention si je
passe par là peut-être que je peux aller
la voir
ouais en fait il faudrait aller manger
ce cavalier
et peut-être contamineront anglais va le
mettre le fou en d3 ça peut être une
idée
une idée un match déjà du masters france
est donc j'imagine que les noirs et d'un
vestiaire 3 1 8% comme ça on va jouer un
truc comme ça et là du coup tu as trois
quelque part pour avoir pendant ce nas
interdit roi ici pour éviter de se
prendre à une découverte quand même il
est blanc et venait à s'y reprendre à
quatre dans la position va bien un
clouage c'est pour ça qu'il a enlevé sa
tour réussi du visage qui
est
non sur longtemps fond c'est bien pour
les blancs ils ont une faiblesse ce pion
signes laissent caresser une faiblesse
et
voilà et de purée 3 peut aussi être
faible même tour à trois ça peut être ça
peut être un coup clairement ce sont des
citoyens restent l'avoir découverte il
ya des tours un cas des rigolos ils
jouent la même idée pour avoir le canal
y en a pour les manger qui ont fait 3
via la casa patrick
guat rock du tube et trois autres le
pion central anglais 5 mais attention
parce que c'est très très chaud et a pu
passer qui arriverait si ça devient
dangereux on accable roi abdique peut
essayer de prendre la vie mais attention
parce que j'ai aussi impliqué très
dangereux moi aussi mais il a en prise
pour l'instant hilarant prise donc et
j'ai aussi ma tour en prie donc je peux
pas tout faire non plus tomber 8 je
crois pas que ce genre de choses puisse
marcher quoique est-ce que souffrance
après que ça pouvait marcher
j'entends que la cage ouverte et chaque
année à tour en prison et a vu ses rares
cas n'a qu'à ça va aussi mal on tend en
5 plus une ak est très mal autant
effectivement et saint vidal gm à l'otan
mais ça prouve qu'il a des problèmes à
résoudre qui réfléchit beaucoup pas il
n'est pas là mais refait le match ou
d'un coeur et vend dans le temps
alors ici dit il doit être très précis
s'il veut avoir des chances de liens
mais là ça pour attac il est donc là
faut choisir la la bonne case il en a
pas trente-six
l'impression qu'il n'a pas de très
bonnes cases pour sa tour ou bien hésité
peut-être entre loire et d un image in
il va enfin
et e5 est pas du tout
il a parlé d'un cas moi ça a l'air juste
complètement perdant ce qu'il a fait
pour qui va arriver en s'impliquer parce
qu'il ya juste ici deux tours on va
contrôler tombé devant le cube
effacement
nakamura s'est trompé si c'est terminé
les deux pions wada mais s'est dit qu'il
va prendre la tête pour la première fois
du match n'a qu'à moi qui a mal calculé
dans cette finale ouais et franchement
c'est hyper bien que que duke matching
commence pour l'atteindre ça peut faire
douter un petit peu dacca peut-être dans
ce match il peut t'il tew oui petit si
vous étiez là avant la pause
appelez-vous qui pouvait mener 2 0 d'un
cas il était complètement gagnant il a
voulu sacrifier sa d'armes pour le beau
jeu il est oublié un matin dans le coup
il a perdu comme ça ça fait un partout
et maintenant c'est au contraire un
petit peu de tourner donc attention
il me demande ça fait souvent beaucoup
de nuls en 5 + une voix gespunsart
dépend vraiment ouais c'est match il ya
eu des matches où il ya eu je crois dix
parties décisives de suite et d'autres
échanges et les nuls c'est
le premier match que j'avais que j'avais
vu que j'avais mal estimé aronian
justement il ya eu beaucoup de parthenay
6 mai mais il ya eu beaucoup de parties
a perdu autant il risque du coup il
faisait madinier le quoi mais je crois
que c'est contre eux en fait il ya eu
quasiment très très peu de
[Musique]
ouais 2 nuls a way et je crois même
peut-être quasiment 20 parties d'affilée
sans nulle antilles comme ça même
émission que la vie j'adore rendu
alors que alors que nous sommes le
quilleuc irrigue irina cas il y avait
beaucoup de nuls par exemple aguirre
ouais mais n'ont même pas enfin il est
ce honnête joueurs wii beau dire il est
connu pour faire beaucoup de duels et
ses contrôles souvent pour ça mais en
vrai guy mollet mais comment les joues
pas ce qu'il avance t-il ils essaient de
gagner mais malgré lui des voix bas il
paraît que pas terminée ou
ça c'est un très très bon joueur il a
l'air en mauvaises langues on aime bien
troll mais les guérites un bon style 15
en tout cas moi j'aime beaucoup ouais
moi ici qu'il est marrant homogène dame
alors l'apologue pour le championnat du
monde des rallyes évident c'est que
entre le 26 et le 30 décembre
là on est vraiment sur du virtuel sur le
speech elle passe tout ce radar data
mais c'est mieux d'ailleurs c'est
beaucoup mieux d'avoir les deux
tournants présentiel quand même ah bah
oui c'est sûr ça change tout ça change
tout c'est lui 3 + 2 je pense enfin
que ce doublé c'est vrai d'une 15 +10
l'art à pied doit
nous sa race qui va jouer je ne crois
j'en ai aucune idée j'en sais rien je
sais qu'en france à maxime qui va jouer
fil rouge à il joue aussi avec nos deux
cartes scène va jouer le gendarme
allemand aussi il me semble que il me
semble que nakamura jouera aussi un jeu
normalement oui ils avaient dit qu'ils
étaient motivés
parce que d'un cas c'est vrai que
darragi l'a pas fait les championnats du
monde un de ses rapides qui loge pas
pourquoi ses meilleurs joueurs non mais
ça fait même plusieurs zones d'afrique
qui les faisait par un je pense a fait
au moins 3 4 ans qui n'a pas joué le
mérite du sang chez elle
libye le journal et bilan fourni la
vraie peut-être d'avoir une wild card
croit il avait dit que non mais je crois
que c'était en espagne que ça me motive
à mon avis peut-être que c'est un garçon
à walker
baisse et ça c'est une invitation au
plateau ouais mais pour moi comme sa
hauteur
en fait il faut avoir au moins il faut
2501 d'être assez 25,50 ses 25,5 en
janvier et décembre de cette année à
voir vivre au moins une fois dans 550
soir à mes services classiques
auxquelles tout croche à kazan quelqu'un
je crois que trop bien fait et du coup
n'ont pas de jouer du troll je crois que
les organisateurs ils peuvent donner
jusqu'à
ses 12 invitation hockey en plus quelque
chose comme ça les crimes j'ai oublié
mes mais moi c'est un droit qui n'équipe
que chaque jour qui ferait trop de
jouets bon j'ai pas niveau 1 fota mais
même avancer maintenant c'est ce que je
préfère sur beat ouais
c'est cool tu es plus j'ai quand même
temps c'est chaud bas c'est une
tellement bien
mais
mais non moi je certainement que je peux
je rêverais de faire un robin vient même
que j'aurais jamais 25 50
/ / / caisse comme je les aimais c'est
tout d'abord inverser la croix ce soit
quelques points à prendre ah oui oui je
suis pas loin je prenne mon départ je
suis pas là il reste que que 200 points
présenté sa
+50
hélas combien de temps là dans cette
cadence il reste 21 minutes 34 d'actes
manqués que la dîme via je regarde la
position et j'aime beaucoup les noirs
j'ai l'impression que depuis le début du
match en fait ça a toujours bien bauer
lors du ca au moins égale est souvent un
petit peu mieux
et là il a ses deux fours braqué il a le
sang la société est mauvais en b2 qui
joue pas du tout donc peut-être que naka
il va devoir arrêter un petit peu son
cavalier 3g trois croix rouge et de
jaune a rien à [ __ ] de ce que tu fais
toujours la même chose
comment les dragons essayer de
progresser
peut-être jamais clé tour au centre et
avancer les pions
secondes je dois
je dois faire quelque chose j'aurais eu
pendant deux secondes basée
à la moitié de la cadence pour retourner
chez moi j'aurais été chaud pour se
redire mais fait partie car
je pense qu'on va rester sur un car pour
l'instant
en a qui a fini par jouer h3 tour g1 ses
poèmes ça c'est un petit peu le plan par
défi
de mini rocks aménager la dans le coin
pas vraiment qu'on juge ma quel état
d'esprit depuis dix ans je pense qu'ils
voulaient enlever sa tour pourra jouer
un deux trois soleil et le fooding et
blanches des noirs dans la grande blague
ou vers le bas ça pèse sur la tour f 1
donc il veut essayer de le tranquilliser
pour ça qu'il a dû faire face à un
thorzain est un petit peu bizarre je
suis revenu
ça jamais aucune idée
coco l'asticot sur la vie si la longue
les bibliothèques
les dealers à dubaï
en argentine
non c'était mon pote la fait pas chez
moi l'un chez un ami qui me prête son
ordi pour stream est ce que le mien
c'est je suis pas sûr que qui tiennent
tout le stream déjà à sa serait
problématique ben j'avais fait la
première fois avec avec kevin terrieux
et hors du temps s'était éteint pendant
le stream il y avait trop gillaque trop
chauffé et je dis bon quand même donc je
sais mieux la de maîtrise chez lui
du coup on en était à essayer de barnes
que la position du canada il a fait
vraiment un plan par des pieds et il
subit et c'est par amandine a quand même
poussé
bois 4 c'est bien aujourd'hui mais la
pression et veut ouvrir la ligne en fait
sous et la position dacca parce qu'on
prend c'est ça qui est faible il joue
sur trois rangées avec les plans il est
étendu la plus d espace domine je pense
que à trois sites ils menacent un pur je
vous arrête le foot est vraiment
complètement fermée en être plus
sage et avait une république pense qu'il
essaie terme à cinq et à trois derrière
damas cinq attaques et lecavalier et
ensuite faire à trois mètres le faut en
être un petit peu mieux dans les levées
comment se joue un match comme ça que se
passe-t-il après dix minutes après on va
jouer en 3 plus une rom peac3 pour une
heure une heure et ensuite on aura une
demi-heure de
demi heure de
de plus les temps une plus une
poster cannes poster du film douze
hommes en colère douze hommes en colère
monte chez
ma recommandation à l'achat d'oeuvres
d'art c'est un très vieux film qui date
des années 1950 et la faisait les
diplômes qu'ils
servent encore aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'intensité beaucoup
de questionnements ce sont ces superbes
sièges douze hommes en colère ça
marchera stocks n'avait conseillé à
l'époque moi je pense est très très très
beau film franchement moi je vais
plusieurs fois je voudrais bongo dans le
tchat je suis très heureux
là vous avez un bon prof de philo
fait monsieur pablo les quinze joueurs
des chefs
j'ai mauvaise langue on peut
alors que deux fois à 3 donc les gars du
gros problème est qu'avec trop fort et
si vous ou kim joue pas
alors que rebelles et b5 madoff
made in game à l'otan donc faut prendre
si tu ne marche pas un d'un point qu'a
lieu cette fourchette parce qu'il y aura
foule prend un cavalier f5 avec un
fermier flèche
tout à fait toujours très bon pour moi
aussi
battant philo c'est en terminale donc du
coup c'est un an dernier peut-être qu'il
vient d'avoir 18 ans qui ya droit de
rester
près ça vaille les figures du matin
le week-end des vacances de nos réelles
bon
en tout cas nacac et cette attention je
m'en veux iliad 1.6 qui arrive en 4 3 3
voilà pourquoi la suite je sais pas le
cas mais j'ai trois parce que kheddam g3
je mange là j'ai peur qu'il se passe à
renier qui est ici dit mais alors que
l'on a une qualité avance ça me fait
peur ça ok prise prise fou prend 1,3 et
il ya peut-être tour d2 qui peut arriver
complètement gagnant il est en train de
se faire un peu macabre mouret j'ai
envie de dire assez typique de la kf3
peut être mal un regard d'andreu deux
effets retour j'ai un site dix des
onze jeux super tour je sais plus qui va
à dame nature qui a très choquant naka
qui il ya cinq secondes pour 10 mais
attention trois secondes
ya la dame en prise à des gros points en
pratique c'est très dur avec cette
position en acceptant une jour il va la
faire
deux secondes en tout cas matin il est
pas content a qu'un il faut que je bouge
à la tête les pas contents mais mais
voilà mal à la remise par des rites
sacrés la dame pourquoi il a fait ça
mais il a plus de temps
d'un terrible pour jean cette année
il avait massacré positionnement
stratégique
et s'est écroulée à cause de la pendule
et de dakar parce que d'un car bien sûr
à trouver des ressources incroyables
et quand même à trois nuits trois et
demi donc c'est ça reste ça reste encore
largement jouable un jeu vous dire bah
ouais il ya là plus breaké à faire un
petit plus de la côte n'a qu'à s'en va
être quand même hyper intéressant
d'avoir un peu comme un golfeur réagi
dans les prochaines parties
est emmené à plus deux comme ça
donc
on n'en est pas encore là ouais non mais
je te dit avant le match dans le match
contre aronian la majorité des partis ça
se terminait autant quoi pour parler de
ces terminologies et mais bon oui ok
avec même s'il est tombé de disposer
matéco ouais mais bon enfin qu'en fait
quand il a moins de dix secondes tu sais
que grease tombe à tous les couples
aussi précis
et donc du haut alors que alors que
alors que d'un cas avec division 2
sachant rien fait à la simple c'est sûr
et c'est la grosse différence je pense
dans ce match intense face en tout cas
c'est ce qui peut faire la différence
dans ce match parce que là termes de
niveaux bas tingle à quoi cette partie
elle illustre bien positionné un machin
dean cain a priori stratégiquement qui
est plus fort que d'un cas mais après
dans le petit jeu pratique en fin de
partie la naga
largement au dessus vous
chacun joué sur leurs forces et
faiblesses et malheureusement suspecte
peut être que ça
ça a tourné
par où je pense pas que dimitile dans
ses pas son genre
normalement elles restent bien
concentrés c'est la deuxième demi-finale
du rhin semaine
et la finale aura lieu dimanche ne sait
pas encore à quelle heure
cette variante on l'a déjà vu en
plusieurs fois chaque fois et des petits
ajustements de parts et d'autres mais
peut-être un petit peu plus à chaque
fois pour le blanc mais rien de très
très convaincante du cul
de four des simples qui est toujours
très puissant des petits fasse attention
des fois il ya des cartes et on se
retrouve enfermé au centre avec ses 500
pêche ça se prend voilà depuis casse de
suite enlevé sept à huit exactement
c'était un coup assez prudent
donc faut à 8 que vous ceux défendus c
est toujours important quel faux se
défend dur avec to b s'étirer pour y
avoir des fois des petites
découvertes où il faut voir donc avoir
les pièces défendu entre est toujours un
avantage les t-shirts ne pas les perdre
est sûr de pas se faire enfumer
donc x 8 comment provoquer une lente et
re5 de 5 et 5,5 à magnan leucate comme
ça ça fait pas mal non c'est chaud à
candidatures donnent des cases pour ton
anniversaire on a 1 0 ce week end non
j'ai toi tu prends des cases noires une
conciliation mais tu obtiens avantage on
a prévalu mais qu'est-ce qui est le plus
bénéfique et pour qui parce qu'en soit
11,5 dans la case des cinq mais tu
gagnes la case de 4 est aussi le cas des
options en ce sens qu'il est important
parce qu'ils chassent le cavalier et ses
skis qui est des chansons du roi valet
qui défend le droit qui est important et
du coup une fois qu'on le chasse mais il
ya plus personne pour défendre le roi
donc c'est un coût qui tourne toujours
intéressant agents tout cas qu'il ait
cinq cavaliers aux quatre au dancing du
coup c'est une fabrique africaine a
appris comme kb24 le pion des 4 va être
échangé et le puits sera vulnérable sur
l'emballage donc le 5 c'est qu'un
ça c'est un pari quoi on joue pour la
table si vous regardez un cavalier pour
des soins de 5 pour revenir à la sépare
ces cas pour venir défendre 5 venir au
des six c'est possible aussi mais via un
call parce qu'il veut dire faire cette
case là mais du coup à voir si je peux
manger là et après avoir ce petit pion
est donc oui c'était prendre des tours
regardez la défense du pion
or je pense qu'à position à compliquer
si tout peut se passer
encore une structure de pions symétrie
qu'ils aiment bien mais évoquer la
symétrie s'arrête là
quand même des différences importantes à
près
de dijon est là les points qui nous
avons en septembre en liquide ce qui
peut arriver j'ai un cabri quatrième
place en d5 aussi donc chacun à c'est
assez bien en face à l'imposition c ca
ca qui vibrait quand même
arcade et 6 dont 4 c est au tour de vis
temps je pense qu'on va avoir un de ces
coups là
plutôt on sait c'est pour essayer
plutard de doubler sur la colonne des
peut-être un jour on débute et va
enfoncer par ailleurs ça fait trois
coups tour c'est un héritage est en
prise
y'a pas dans l'hudson mondiale il
revient en 17 tours 7 plus précis un ca
des femmes cavalli la même menace pas
cavalier prendrait cinq maintenant etc
les noirs qui avaient des moyens ça peut
être une menace après qu'ubs allait
prendre l'empreinte et 6
attention dit mid apparaissent à des
cavaliers la lose my iphone
4s qu'on pense que firent roja va
devenir champion du monde dans les
prochaines années bon c'est pas vraiment
vous tous mouillé que de dire oui en
tout cas c'est sûr que c'est le
principal prétendant mais vu son âge
c'est largement le voir le clip en ta
génération rescue départ à champion du
monde c'est impossible de répondre mais
bon tout cas où j'espère on a envie pas
forcément parce que parce qu'ils
habitent en france l'été naturalisé
français moi j'aime déjà avant j'aimais
note son style en fait sont qui joue
toujours pour gagner à kiel pleurs il
aime le jeu qu'ils aiment prendre des
risques du tout les positions à fond
donc là un style vraiment rafraîchissant
et donc ça donne envie
mais encore très jeune il faut qu'ils
engrangent de l'expérience
même s'il a déjà 2800 rénaux il a encore
jeune et il faut encore qu'il fasse un
pas l'un c'est pas
mais bruit sûr qu'il a un potentiel
extraordinaire
et en plus ça q départ de carol scène
peut-être et bien ça pourra aider aussi
y apprit les bras par partie car là il
n'est pas encore parti
il a 31 ans
alors materia et
maury dynamique dit ben
mords et je veux qu'il a participé aux
vices kenzy l'open
bêta fermée qui qualifie haut a donc
serré dès janvier il a volé un vélo
c'est un tournant qui est très très fort
et qui est point besoin de lui qui avait
quasiment que des jeunes qui jouaient
tous des jeunes auraient sais c'est un
très très bon tournoi pour lui c'est
cool qui sont acquis qui sont invités
parce qu'on n'a vraiment prestige
de ouf et du coup on sait bien qu'ils
fassent ça
après en tant que trop parler d'eux
parce que ben ben y'a pas trop trois
tournois le temps reprennent petit à
petit et puis du coup ben voilà un jeu
que matériel a fait d'ailleurs sa
deuxième nombre de mettre un tournoi de
du cap d'agde
les cannes à deux enfin à deux nombres
de m pardon à l'âge de
12 ans qui s'applique elle agit là il
petit il est très très jeune et il a
deux ans 2 m et 23 50 moment de prêts en
lots donc j'ai d'ailleurs je pense que
la progression suit son cours normal
certaines spéciales mais mais
malheureusement voilà il ya pas trop de
tournois pour l'instant donc c'était
pour ça quand on pas trop parler d'eux
mais mais ils sont là ils progressaient
travail et puis on la verra bientôt
encore celui sous les projecteurs la
d'ici quelques années voilà c'est sûr
enfin samedi finale n'a qu'à deux
minutes d avance qu on al impression que
commence à jouer plus vite on s'est déjà
préparé pour le peut-être ne croit plus
c'est plutôt sympa
et on a un créateur de cavaliers lors de
tous
je côte à côte attention fourchette là
pour le coup j'avoue parce que les
cavaliers puisque roy qui arrive
manquerait plus que le roi noir arrivent
dans le set vous allez voir qu'il va y
avoir des fourchettes
moi ça me préparera mort à cause des
fourchettes sur 138 ma vie j'aurai un
peu partout aux tracas j'aurais peur
avec les deux couleurs est objectivement
à peu près égales moi je mange me
connaissent et même comme ak c'est que
c'est moi le problème en fait c'est à
dakhla et oui ce changement prendra une
club et surtout avec tout ce qu'on a
c'est bien le problème pour digne anne
c'est la gestion du temps là ça me fait
de plus en plus peur ce match n'est pas
et bien sûr un qu'à ce niveau il ya des
fourches à l'air bien sûr on essaie des
ex pensionnaires vie et en en blessant
dans l'apathie qu'il ya beaucoup d'art
de match
beaucoup de partis c'est une seconde de
déconcentration
c'est clair que ça arrive alors bien sûr
ça arrive jamais en partie classique non
non mais là on en blitz on en blitz
attention que six manches là il peut pas
partir comme ça et c'est d'aller manger
un peu ailleurs un cabas et des
6,7 non mais qui décide en fait des
progrès mais là ça va être complètement
mégalo mais c'est le temps qui peut
accueillir
les impressions pour noir quand même
avec le roi qui peut finir il peut être
plus actif mais bon ce pion payet faible
un échec
oui ça va être nul mais mais bon ding à
13 secondes et la position est plus
facile à jouer pour les problèmes noir
pas grand-chose de 2,1 me juste il ya
toutes les pressions je pense surtout
l'excellent mickaël de chambre va la
jouer le maximum là il va il va essayer
de faire ce qu il va tourner être
détournés en espérant en placer une
fourchette
un gros magouilleurs et je pense que
dakar le 6 même le fait de jouer la
partie russe pour que le temps tourne
c'est un truc qui pourrait arranger un
pour ce format il s'il n'est pas déjà
peut-être à calculer comme ça dès minuit
non en fait je pense que il préfère gelé
car
c'est aussi un plateau à cela ils
attaquent ils attaquent apps est quand
même fin mai il avait été placé là
d'accord je pense qu'on avait besoin de
faire un double effort
là ça va être dur maintenant de fermer
ce qu'un échec un cavalier f5 ça peut
être jouable et c'est tout le sel là
avec elle va les prendre la messine et
cabella disparaît cela pour beaucoup
normalement ce devrait facilement
pratique mais s'ils changent structure
avec ce plan de secours est faible avec
pas
mais bon rien alors le quément d'accord
quant à moi de votre balade sans les
cavalières c'est vrai que en plus option
est faible toujours à mon combat c'est
de manger un petit rhume
à tour des échecs au soir dans un dhimmi
peut perdre parce que la franchise était
là pour quatre secondes il a perdu 10
secondes ne sais pas pourquoi il était
dans le bon rythme il y à perdre sauf
pour le set ok et charles manger nos
toits mais
je calme quelque 125 g 5 3e set
probablement toujours nus l'un des ses
six mois attention la tour
et choc il ya pas d
par
cinq mois c'est aussi plus simple et il
a fini par perdre le bourget lors deux
contre un
alors qu'ils finissent par la perdre
marc comment on fait pour pour gagner le
plongeur a précédemment il peut attendre
juste et accroît g20 m
qu'est ce qu'il ya faire dakar etc
tricotent
et détricotent
modding on a compris sa stratégie
ils veulent changer pourquoi il a changé
ou pierre d'accord ça marche bien d'une
manière pas changé c'est vrai mais bon
ok je comprends c'est du pareil au même
elle peut pas de la maison ranger carte
bref je pense à un truc comme ça avant
mais il dit du coup qui jugent et 4 ok
quelques dessins qu'il ya un tournoi qui
va arriver welch attention attention
cavalli qui n'ont pas de fourchette
je travaille sur les stades tu l'as en
arriver là pour chacun un petit cavalier
dans l'acte dix cavaliers detroit là ça
fait peur
moi j'aborde avec le noir
déjà au 85e coup assez insupportable
pour les mères
il reste trois minutes à 9050 dans le
temps au temps a il a donné pions parce
qu'il faut qu
il a pris la ville a bougé les rois
mélasse perdent pas ce qu'on va avoir
une nouvelle partie parce qu'ils
assument 40 ans
c'est encore gagné non mais oui oui je
comprends ceux des travailleurs petits
tas c'est la crise mais bon c'est parti
c'est plus mental pas encore
attention
attention il va se faire la finir par
ça ne marche pas
il a indiqué quand même du bien car il
sait que ces quatre cavaliers cigaline
ça a changé les pièces à l'e3 libye mais
ces échanges et la pièce ressemble et
l'échec
c'est sûr qu'il va te reprendre mais là
c'est sûr ça commence à la gamme
découverte par toi la gagne fourchette
basse et par delà ses parents 26 bougies
roi ici un fourchette et s'il me voit
ici eh ben il avait
cloué
en 107 coup il a perdu il reste 40
secondes dans le temps réglementaire
dont tous la première partie avant
la prochaine section
de me perdre deux parties à la suite
[Musique]
qu'ils auraient pu ne pas perdre quand
même aux victimes en
avant les plus belles voix fatou qui qui
veut voir les pubs 1 est la fin je crois
qu'elle est venue la bourse en vedette
en fout du match elle va rien ce jeudi
matin
ouais le potentiel aussi de ce qu'on
pense que potentiellement c'est très
spéculative justement les deux thomas
par rapport à une nouvelle
c'est dur à dire on est devant moi j'ai
joué le contre mais même cette chance
malchance de l'occurrence celle perdue
quand j'étais petit quand je suis à 30
jeunes l'année 11 ans il jouait déjà
dans les catégories à moins de
moins de 15 ans j'avais 14 ans je
n'avais déjà le premier héros et j'avais
pu analyser la partie avec lui à
l'analyse il était à une telle vitesse
que j'ai connu plus tôt dans le top 10
des jeunes de mon âge j'avais
l'impression d'être un pouce encore
j'avais été vraiment particulièrement
impressionné je sais je pense pas que
les les deux petits sets puissance de
calcul aussi extraordinaire que maxime
après il n'ya pas que ça aussi comme
force du droit
en tout cas ils sont ils formés par fait
pour être de badens
dans l'élite 1 peut être un jour on
verra mais on a beaucoup de choses à
faire 1 2413 ne suffit pas il faut viser
les 2800 et c'est rien à voir c'est trop
tôt en fait pour pouvoir rendre compte
déjà des desama j'avais vu lui était
revenue car la scène enfin on l'avait
demandée en fait ce qu'ils pensaient de
près d'un land à l'époque c'était avant
les avants les les l'épidémie est tous
là et il avait de 1100 lots à 15 16 ans
donc c'est énorme énorme et en fait
ouais nan mais il n'est pas un poisson
sais pas mais on va voir si jamais ils
passent 2007 et à quel âge et voilà en
fait dit cinquantaine pour lui aurait
débuté sa saison c'est pas révélateur
enfin
avis la patte de 1600
ok il se dit que bien sûr c'est un
palier et m même si ce sera extrêmement
tu as beaucoup de joueurs si vous me
lisez ça
mais après c'est derrière voir comment
tu continues derrière à progresser si tu
passes de en fait y'a pas de cap pas de
cap et il ya des joueurs qui peuvent
avoir un cap tu réussiras
avoir un cap très très tôt mais après
derrière les blocks plus fin
ça dépend de plein de choses donc
malheureusement ça dépend aussi de leur
vie personnelle en fait comme on pose la
question est ce qu'il va devenir pro et
les études club parfois chez antalis est
bien plein de leur famille leur rends
toi il ya tellement fait de paramètres
qui rentrent en ligne de compte c'est
impossible de savoir à quand ils ont
entreposé qu'un drone qu'est ce qui va
se passer dans l'orient il ya un monde
où j'ai trop il faut juste arrêter les
guichets car abandonné parce que les
choses sont plus intéressants
moi cela après voilà fil rouge à lui ça
il a atteint le cap des des 2800 même un
petit peu avant il était déjà dans le
top 10 top 15 mondial vous n'avez déjà
la réponse à cette question qu'il allait
franchir ces paliers là
mais il a 18 ans les autres la faim en
tout cas les deux français sont encore
trop jeunes
sachent vraiment fallait en parler bien
sûr on parle de l'élite mondiale donc là
pour répondre à ces questions c'est pas
après bien sûr pour leur âge ou
ccc enfin s'il de deux parcs on sait
comment ils sont là et mais bon après
même comparé les joueurs entre eux
j'aime pas trop parce que ça ça dépend
de plein de choses
donc on verra
on verra en tout cas mais mais ils sont
prometteurs en tout cas ça c'est déjà
demain m
alors par exemple maxime la garde des
hussards
bayrou se demander est ce que le
potentiel pour aller jusqu'à 18h sur une
passe impossible de savoir c'est
toujours pas maintenant mais ça va
dépendre d'eux s'ils ont envie de
travailler
finalement est-ce que 25 ans par exemple
ils sont
pressés dans les chemins de
déjà avant ici vous de savoir évidemment
là tu vois qu'ils ont quasiment 26,50
tous les deux ils sont très forts ils
pourraient être etc mais après ben tu
sais pas si ce qui va se passer dans
leur vie si vraiment ils ont envie de
jouer de me le mal enfin faire un effort
et le travail parce que c'est là on peut
se dire oui il manque 50 prendre il
manque 50 points à ce niveau là c'est
énorme c'est pas comme un dj khalil 50
points 2 trouve que c'est pourri ça
plus chaque
nom et puis pour gagner une partie à
leur niveau c'est c'est
dur quoi c'est pas une gaffe il prendra
un coup comme nous on fait un score mais
franche atteint c'est c'est un autre jeu
pas et donc
donc non il pas passé 27 ans y'a pas de
problème mais c'est vrai que c'est
ce qu'a qui je le connais ce cas qui
sait muscat qui
merci à toi bonne idée jetez rien de le
dire il ya ce bonus est à toi et merci
d'être passé d'avoir suivi le match avec
nous et à très bientôt ce cas qui
est pour les trois mille lots a
peut-être sur le très très très très
long terme s'il ya une inflation du vélo
mais
l'e3 l'année 1 3011 non on le verra mais
non nous on ne verra pas nourrir les
vers hazard moi je serai peut-être trois
finalement nous on ne verra pas mais un
jour je pense ce sera atteint avec
l'inflation quand y'aura plus pas mal de
jours d'avis 2008 2009 peut-être dans
dans dans mille ans lorsque la réponse
là tu peux faire des calculs
mathématiques statistiques il peut avoir
une prédiction à mon avis sauf que les
stats c'est pas pour moi alors je
m'amusais à part ça je vous laisse ma
place
volontiers
donc je vous ai de
wendy égalise là quand même hein il a
encore mieux avec les noirs et les nerfs
il avait il à la paire de foule à ses
deux petits pions là qui sont un pas qui
créent qui vraiment resterez nos petits
tours de l'année on voit les vous des
neutrons ne passive
le top 30 mondial je gagne très bien sa
vie ouais
c'est pas mal fait mais la grosse
différence par top 10 les joueurs ont
trop misé par la 15e et la 30e moi je
pense que c'est
le 10 premiers rôles titres mieux je
pense que c'était vraiment bien après
après c'est ce qu'ils les cycles à
chaque fois d'une berton
tous les grands prix restent hostiles
les grands les saint-louis des trucs sur
internet les
grands chefs tour là c'est là où les
prix sont très intéressants des instants
tu intègres ce circuit là tu viennes
très rentable
je suis d'accord avec toi qu'il ya à
chaque fois je déteste les positions de
naka aussi avec mes plans naka ils
seront malmenées dans les ouvertures en
tout cas et du cubana léa douze mois les
poser problème du coup pascal amel pêche
dans la finition
barak n on avait eu aussi lautier à
l'époque à joël optique est un super
joueur donc j'aimerais score positif
contre car la star c'est ça je vais
lautier qui avait quasiment deux mille
sept cents lots dans les années 90 1
et
années 90 enfin
je sais pas combien ça vaut à peu près
enfin un mot combien ils étaient je dire
dans
le classement mondial mais c'était
c'était un c'était un des meilleurs
espoirs français et peut-être même de ce
que moi j'écoutais parce qu'à l'époque
j'étais pas gd ce projet je suis dans 90
bouquet est en fait divisée que lautier
c'était peut-être peut-être et encore
plus prometteur que l'été est une
backroom hakim h les rameurs très
aventure j'avais détiennent aussi est
vraiment
les trois auraient pu aller plus loin il
aurait pu aller plus haut
il y avait le potentiel pour
losier monde était peut-être un peu seul
en termes de français d'entrer au niveau
de sa génération à l'époque était doux
sauvage et etienne
aussi je pense que c'était etienne et
les autres quoi
mais bon derrière et les poussait qu
elles l ont finalement quelques mains
lapiro jacques a rejoint maintenant
l'équipe de france mais
c'est un peu différent donc c'est un peu
différent
on prend mais c'est différent a bien sûr
là c'est pas des déformations française
quoi et alors on fait signe à lui bien
sûr très fort joueur aussi mais pas
quand même au niveau par exemple de
etienne rate etienne bacrot en termes de
potentiel
dans les coups de barrière comme ils
étaient gagnés derrière
l'as la crise gamin c'est la crise on
voit quand même que le roi blanc leur
clan qui va il va bien s'ouvrir la route
de quake 3
segments très à l'est de damas et de
daria par le roi noir il très très bien
défendu
exact mais bon 26 secondes pour ding et
on sait bien que ça se passe mal quand
il est là
ces deux là écrasant quand même mais bon
il faut il faut il faut défendre la
cogeca vraiment fou aussi c'est bien
aussi
ok alors mangez pas faisait 4 parce que
il y aurait trop franck et je pars aussi
madame maria s'est encore pas si facile
comment tu passes ce que tu as un
environnement abonde ça c'est pas grave
very bad things you on va gagner la
partie adverse là je vous laisse musical
déjà si tu ranges avant là que je perds
genre forte des deux
côtés deux dames d un
prix de prise il me changer atteindre 5
il a beaucoup du fou a trop à ce qu'un
fou à quoi ça peut arriver à l'heure
d'hiver peut être ai je vais pousser mon
animal naisse qu'il a fait quand même
dit que je crois oui là il à changer des
pièces pour essayer de capturer l'un est
le plus ancien qu'on s'en foutent et en
fait ça m'offre limites y adonner à
l'honneur ça donne john edwards à
caillavet encore il ya aucun france a
retiré
et il ajouté rien à vis tu n'as qu'à le
lob de leroy 4 5 secondes sabrina il a
séché réussi ta position maintenant
comment tu passes
c'est dommage que didier chenet touche
quand c'était sa grosse erreur d'avoir
un changement en attaque il ya trois
secondes à la pendule web et c'est rien
ça promet ouais c'est pas un rappeur
vient juste
dit que l'âge de 6 ou et il a raison de
la jouer parce qu'il a ce prix en b3 là
où il se passe quoi la fin au projet des
orangers 2 de reposer non mais j'ai pas
dit qu'il a raison je dis que je
comprends mais bien sûr ça ses mails
allez on met le coin f5
il ya plus de temps bah c'est la pause
ça les gars ont fait nul à les
vaincus aux sections s'expose au large
de 400 répète notre corps est un leurre
c'est quand même yes alors les gars on
va vite vous envoyer tout âge depuis
puisque fatou sinon on risque de le
faire quand même venu pour ça hein on va
quand même essayer de vous offrir cette
belle page de pub donc on revient on
croyait le samu d'ici six minutes max
enfin il peut amener un peu avant cinq
minutes voilà de rien que pour toi à
très bientôt à tout
[Musique]
nous sommes revenues les gars donc
la portion de 3 fut sulky
qui commence à l'instant
donc ça me qu'est parti ce point tout en
gardant la pose des voies là ça fait du
bien c'est inception vinaigre pape
tiggelen
escale meyers tout c'est parce qu'ils
aiment ou pas on l'a connu à mais le
vinaigre c'est assez spécial quand même
il faut aimer
les gens que des gens les gens qui
aiment le film nous avons collé am les
chips au vinaigre normalement ça va
il va l'écouter on va de ce pas voir
je ne dis pas à toi que j'ai fait
pendant la pause par tous
les mondes activités culinaires mais il
atteint il fait aussi intéressante
bah je me suis fait un petit marteau
comme
je sais pas si on va avoir plus de trois
épreuves la santé quand même il veut
écoutes illégales le vinaigre magrin là
moi je vais moi je vais voter un samassa
du l'ex amie qui va vous être l'autre
côté bien sûr
merci d'une saisie de quelqu'un qui a du
goût
cc rien presque aussi c'est avec le
match
ah bon alors là ça y est c'est
l'échappée
mais beckham passarieu quoi gagner la
prédiction a salué sur les chips qui
fait quoi il connaît des chips au
vinaigre sans déconner quoi a bien juste
c'est pas un barbecue je sais pas à quoi
la rupture mais
la passe est fini mais n'importe quoi
juste à tous au vinaigre tout celui mer
c'est une autre catégorie quoi la chips
au vinaigre ces 47 ch tis barbecue c'est
paprika par avance très bien comment
après 15h 13m on essaie richard rapport
à chips et à prix canon
n'est pas dans la même catégorie cheaps
quoi
on peut passer existe un pas tous hein
ça existe et je te conseille d'écouter
tu vas être déçu
à l'époque les rib et moi moi il ya des
substrats au vinaigre et à la moutarde
que j'ai vraiment du mal je trouve pas
en fait ni l'un ni l'autre
tout le reste baboo légumes j'en ai
mangé un mais quand j'étais enfant je
n'ai pas les chips au vinaigre une fois
devenu
adulte ça veut dire que la ville ça veut
dire que je ferai quand je serai grande
je reprendrai
pas accessible en fait la première
bouchée n'étions du tout
dans une autre dimension avec la chips
au vinaigre
je pense que dans la camorra et dames et
chez le vinaigre
futilement j'ai vu qu'il aime bien les
red bull c'est possible parce que
dégueulasse madame robert
lepage plupart des sections dégueulasse
que l'internât
est lui sinon
les chips fromage et les bret aux
comptes et du jura je crois qu'ils sont
pas mal mais celles ci n'ont s est pas
bon mais des brèdes ce quadriller
les corps et pamiers c'est très bon
jusque là mais c'est mon jardin c'est
pas des chips les biscuits yates comme
ça
l'accueil est ainsi intégrée alors je
t'annonce que tu donnes gagné 13 12 ton
qui règlent ça fait plaisir et a
honnêtement les gars je suis le rempart
faire de vous
on a on a un chat de qualité
j'sais pas quoi dire il a encore une
position symétrique c'est pas quoi te
dire pense que le débat sur les chiffres
c'était beaucoup plus intéressant que
cette loi en vrai en vrai l'argent
ne se passe pas grand chose on n'a qu'à
mène au mont
with ça ne devrait faire qu'une autre
nul ou de victoire de na carence en zinc
ou grâce à la part dieu
sera pardonnée
je perds pas cependant pas une seconde à
ce jeu perd parce que j'ai pas vu de
sauvages que jamais en effet bornage du
goûter collectif au
nom mais j'ai pas vu ça j'avais vu que
daniel loge qui n'a pas suivi les
sondages mais il aurait sûrement votent
pour moi
ces chips chips a chiffré à jouer en
chips touché chic ce monde j'ai commencé
comme pierre boucher pièce à jouer dans
cet art dubaï
on reprend pas ses coûts
hassan théorie très intéressante car on
voit peut-être que les couche-tard
aime les chips au vinaigre c'est qu'on
peut faire a finalement une
rapprochement
sociologique
ça fait sens
je crois qu'on va arrêter ce débat sur
les chips
à l'échiquier à l'ancienne c'est pas mal
aussi oui sa main à l'ancienne c'est
très bon s'est tenue préférée d'ailleurs
la troisième dose elle foule à flaine
par la troisième dose de chips au
vinaigre ça passe pour la
beaucoup moins à mon humble avis
alors et puis on va se changer et je
pense qu'on va avoir droit qu'à trois
des six et un échange massif de pions
d'un droit de manger et noir du matin à
pas d'heure 1 pour les chips
moi j'ai pas mangé nice matin ni après
midi et ce soir
tu vas tu évanouir en plein direct j'ai
fait un jeune aujourd'hui sans le
vouloir j'avais plein de trucs à faire
aujourd'hui j'ai pas trop eu le temps
je mangerai là-bas je suis d'accord
[Musique]
de quoi il parlait d'une barque du
chiffre et je tenais je peux vu un bon
très bon
mon accord complet ouais c'est ça c'est
brett social celui de meilleur
cette finale de cavaliers dit quoi
maintenant on parle de chips donc ouais
ça me donne faim voire actifs propres à
santos n'a pas mangé de la journée
déclare j'ai vraiment j'ai pas eu le
temps en fait aujourd'hui j'ai trop en
tout cas faire
je suis un ministre gars
n'ont pas trouvé j'ai déménagé je
déménage et
du café à toi
à barbiche il apparaît que toi déchets
solides on peut vite devenir addict un
car je pense qu'il existe
des clubs de mangeurs de chips au
vinaigre anonyme qui sera une miss
torn décidément m'arrêter je les cracks
l'élagage il eut à pâques et je vais les
derniers cours et comment tu peux
comment tu peux être un peu comment tu
peux être un croc intrigue aussi
dégueulasse que j'assiste comment c'est
possible en fait pas debout
alors qu'havas les absences validé y
avait des absents que l'accusé était
alors à mantoue monte on descend
merci à bagnères et balbigny à toi lui à
toi là bas elle
alors chers comme j'ai fait la dernière
fois alors robin c'est le monde famille
de samy en fait ce qu'il veut de sa wii
u se passe c'est pas méchant mieux mais
son prénom tout ça me vois la
commune est
désolidarisée pas par contre jamais
coûté en fait j'en ai vu il ya pas
longtemps je connaissais pas j'ai pas
les pas osé
[Rires]
c'est noël et entraînant du coup daniel
noël n'ont rien à voir
ah mais tu parles des chips ok d'accord
mais ça c'est bon oui ça c'est très bon
je pensais qu'il y avait des chips
spécial parfum crevettes quoi as-tu par
des chips blanche
valentin noël
ça me semblait bien
souvent c'est juste
la revue il ya pas longtemps
la ministre a dit que c'est une très
mauvaise idée de le voir en espagnol ou
en espagnol s'est brisée que des jeux de
mots en français non mais j'ai j'ai gelé
vu pour la première fois en espagnol les
jeux de mots sont pas si mal traduit en
fait pas mal mais je suis d'accord je
suis d'accord
leblanc
ce qu'il dit pour ça d'ailleurs mais
c'est pas les mêmes blagues exactement
mais mewes tu perds beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup en fait quand elle pas dans la
langue malheureusement un court ça fait
que tu peux vraiment bien comprendre et
bien qui fait quand tu es vraiment
français en fait
tu peux changer la cadence
pendant six mois presque j'ai oublié de
changer la cadence ça c'est ma faute par
contre
de bach donnera
merci
à l'écart toujours un point il ya
beaucoup de moulins dans ce match quand
même
beaucoup de yellow
on sait que tu es fan stéphane il est
encore temps de dîner annuel à l'heure
espagnole c'est moi en fait quand le
match est terminé chez moi il va manger
chez moi il sera il sera minuit un faux
pas va donc de couches pour un bol de
johan 3 ans d'un petit kebab sans
oignons tomates salades amin
ok bon voici devant un triple échec
quand même alors tout de suite
non non mais là c'est pas
un problème cette fois ci
donc tours 2 donc moi j'aime bien les
noirs enfin que tu remarques que tu
remarqueras bien que à chaque fois que
le carré blanc le four b2 c'est une
poubelle la global mantoue c'est parti
avec les blancs il n'a jamais été mieux
assortis de arthur il a mieux retourné
des positions basculer là il a un petit
peu arnaquer en tactique mais
positionner louer une chambre dominée
et du coup ci ça dit quoi bouyala père
de fou pour les noirs d'après le fouet
futé pas non plus excellent tout le foot
carte blanche des noirs des sept qui ont
une belle d'agonac tabassant pour des
katas un peu faibles contreparties à
cusset deux équipes est possible ça va
être quand même assez équilibré mais sur
mon petit plus pour les noirs encore une
fois
et à l'équivalent toujours hier c'est
même mieux parce qu'en fait
chez eux leurs parents l'autre leur sort
gt gt en soirée
elle et puis avec deux manqué un petit
peu de
colle donc un peu de rhum et je veux
qu'il doit à ses bons de commandes
est en fait en france que va faire sa
fin c'est je crois qu'il ya d'autres qui
font ça mais ça coûterait très cher et
en fait pour eux c'est pareil tu as tout
ce que le ritz et ben ils ont sous forme
de soi de supermarchés par exemple tiens
il manque un paquet de chips favorite ce
n'est pas bien non mais tu vois et ils
ont raison ils ont ça dans tous les jeux
voix mais
non mais juste bon parce que nous
aimerions que la burqa est responsable
pour la bouffe pour pour tous en fait
tous là ça peut être les restos les
épiceries les magasins comme carrefour
mais toutes et tous morts chevêtres
berry ce nom
en français sur la wii on la met mais
c'est déjà assez des gens avec des
chronos drive des trucs comme ça donc
j'avais qu'on a en france là c'est
vraiment ils te livre chez toi et c'est
comme le beurre en fait c'est la même
page que bear et ou de choisir ce qu'il
veut en magasin si tu veux les payer
j'ai une structure
et je trouve que c'était
après voilà je
pars spécialistes tout ça
non mais là on en sait assez puissant
foot dès 22h
[Musique]
pas qu'en france qu'on se fait avoir
j'ai jamais utilisées par le ritz
bateau est un grand cuisinier toi
banon manfred conduisent pas mais ça me
pour le coup c'est vrai qu'il fait très
bien mon jeu
d'exagérer marc est enfin ok bon je vais
pas me comparer à toi parce que ce
serait top com
[Musique]
non mais ça va être que tu joues bien ça
me bats
ben oui
battant des chips au vinaigre c'est du
taf
côté des mauvais goût ça c'est une chose
mais tu joues bien c'est autre chose
donc c'est plus qu'assez égal 1 encore
une fois on a un site où chacun de
l'ordinaire mais dans la région de noir
et attend de plus pour les blancs mais
qu'ils ne viennent pas d'un quart de
l'activité
croisière 5 fu des 4 donc il ya une
pression pour les noirs parce qu'avec
bouge pas trop à cause du fond du court
métrage en prises moi j'accepte un jouet
toi aussi tu es l'année vient de tourner
moi moi ça doit encore être mieux mais
après il a une il annule quand il veut
un sa seigneurie voilà donc je comprends
chacun des pions à footeux reposer
sheila du président wade a plus trop de
temps pour mettre vous savez que j'aime
toujours ça au pire et la ccnucc facile
jusqu'à quand
il ya juste à attendre et donc encore
une bulle un jeu c'est pas le tout de
nuls sur ce match j'ai l'impression
qu'il ya une partie sera quasiment qui
fait ya beaucoup beaucoup de l'unetel
impuissant
je pense pas que ma cuisine tu as 50 ça
va ça me semble excessif libre à vous
[Musique]
bah écoute fatou me dois par revenir en
france déjà pour tout le monde revient
en france pour organiser un petit
je pense qu'ils se connaissent même pas
de métal
puisque tu as dis pas que j'ai mal lu je
commence à fatiguer russie se
connaissent bien
alors fatou qui attend la réputation de
samy à dîner alors tout à l'heure fatou
qui a écrit dans le chat est de la
demande et si on savait qu'ils invité
pour un dîner de cons et
maintenant elle veut se faire inviter
donc du coup j'ai l'impression qu'elle
elle cherche un petit peu leurs
occupants dès la 2 le bâton pour se
faire battre un kit fait tout un
attention
le jour où sa mine invite à un avis mais
moi je me pose la branche sont proches
pose une question
bah
alors donc ça sera qu on a vu qu'ils
font à partir ici c'est sympa ou au
centre les deux fois en d5 c'est juste
10 bis repetita il ya eu comme ses deux
filles me trompe pas il ya eu ces 5 4 et
fou ah non vous avez des infos à 8 41
foot et rien à 8,1 donc il y avait
encore dans le coup lors je sais ce que
c'est exactement comme coup un
nom qu est ce que je n'ai pas pu y ait
d'autres livres malheureusement pour
l'instant où j'ai écrit un roman que
j'ai ce père
pourra faire publier c'est difficile il
ya peu d'élus pour compliquer d'une
maison d'édition gecko des super retour
donc voilà je me dis que ce n'était pas
encore le moment mais je reste optimiste
pour les soit publiée et puis en plus
est le premier tome d'une trilogie
dans la foulée même si la jeune noir
vraiment vous focalisez sur le deuxième
livre d'échecs avec kevin
mais après moi je préfère écrire des
romans je vous en dehors des méchas car
j'aime beaucoup
intéressant en tout cas
d'un point de vue créatif c'est beaucoup
plus
cool pour moi mais
miser papa ciel c'est un boom de charges
car l'addition
sujet du roman c'est
ça parle des 5 sens de possibilité de
pousser l'un de nos cinq sens à des lé
degré quelque peu inimaginables dans un
univers futuriste une dystopie je suis
une adolescente une héroïne
dans un monde un petit peu ravages
évidemment par tous les excès de
l'humanité
il se passe pas mal de choses pas mal
d'aventuré l'histoire d'amour des
personnages sont inspirés
notamment un certain lien certain
stéphane moreau ben
non c'est pire
la musique nous en partie
au micro espaces dans le micro
il me regardait pas
non justement pourquoi il ya un problème
sur mon micro
c'est un personnage principal
eh ben il ya des petits trolls surtout
bien sûr sur les crudités notamment il
exactement à tous
ces gens retirent que ce qui colle
espère aussi ouais
je friche au duplexe
n'ont jusque-là dans le monde que je
décris on a autour des conditions de vie
moyenâgeuse il ya plus super marché à il
ya plus de chips au vinaigre c'est assez
triste
je prends 10 juin
pas avant sa mort effondrée parce que la
baballe l'espoir
je suis
donc très fort caractère
peut-être que steve ton amoureux de
ruines qui s'est
passé
[Rires]
et on a quand même encore une magnifique
finale
égales par la dix septième nul
consécutif
le supporter alors tous racistes envers
l'on va troquer le pion à contrôler le
pion b maintenant je pense qu'on va on
voit on va continuer à échanger un arrêt
en retour un pour combler le tour qu'on
a cet écart 34 ça va faire un nul
on voit qu'il est a failli tout faire
pour vous en faites le moi savoir
branchement il est là il est vain 21h50
moi je suis assez assez bien encore
est mieux là sa surprise
ouais encore une mieux après les venues
leucan découle beaucoup si je trouve des
choix d'ouverture d'une à quatre mois
mais il sait pas vraiment de prendre
l'avantagé en vain puisque tout se vaut
moins bien et a prévu qu'il joue mieux
avec pas beaucoup de temps il arrive
puis surtout il est content de faire des
bulles puisqu'ils séquence bull est
normalement il est largement meilleur
chaque nul le rapproche un peu plus de
la victoire aux verts dakar essayez-vous
fin chaque partie avec des blancs il est
mal là il est encore barré incroyable de
persister ouais c'est clair mais c'est
souvent ça va même être renvoyée parce
que même dans le match choc à roanne a
souhaité très souvent très mal à quesnoy
répandant kavanagh car la très très mal
toujours un peignoir et de sardan seul
immo et continuer à l'âge où elle a joué
à la joue et il a parlé beaucoup de
participants
c'est vraiment je marchais de sucre et
là bas n'a qu'à continuer à jouer à une
position qui est inférieur à chaque fois
en attaque et blanc à ces fonds par le
même temps après ils arrivent à s'en
sortir relativement rare hector la boue
pas plaisant à jouer je pense pour lui
maintenant d'être toujours lille joue
sur trois rouges à vous regarder dans la
position et noir jouent sur cinq rangées
les melons sur trois est à chaque partie
c'est comme ça à lamballe
ya bien un point d'avancé pas énorme
pâte métal sauf que encore une fois le
problème c'est que normalement ondulait
tenait qu'à moi et la rage le bourg
supérieure à 10
déjà ambulance normalement il ya déjà un
avantage pour n'a qu'à la la il se fait
il se fait pas trop sentir on voit qu'il
ya eu trois parties entrent en plus une
trois parties nulles donc ça reste
encore serré donc on n'a qu'à qui vais
essayer d'aller manger ce pur des trois
quarts maintenant à franchir on va dire
la
[Musique]
barre ya peut-être que voilà dame ces
trois taureaux un tour 3 4 ou pressés
d'aller manger le pion
mais mais bon c'est
en fait ça en échange de ces options le
vrai meurtrier la case des quatre
précédents en fait même si jamais
j'arrive je m'installais que trois des
quatre tours en hand évite ce sujet mme
cavalier qui pour arriver en d4 serait
parfait mais qui amènera pas arrivé
pourquoi il a joué cavalier achète digne
peut-être un jour pour se concilier qui
sait bien aussi sa taxe d'actes axa pour
être à 100 pour être beau mais ça n'a
encore des efforts communs bouger le
[ __ ] une bonne case
prise en jeu trois quais cavale et prend
là j'aime bien l'impression et noir ont
du coup yafo f4 faut être cac avait les
cinq simples comme destin diana des
gâteaux ronds t4
swift 4 j'aime bien dallara dit je vois
qu'il dit + 5 ouais mais après le sprint
dames à 5 pourquoi damas cinq était si
forte attaque est d'arriver à une double
attaque a gagné une pièce intérieure il
n'a pas vu pas facile avec la matinée
ces rixes à gagner à 7 sur le champ
dommage
qu'ils aient une tour de garde ça reste
un bel avantage si tu prends je mange
d'un pion lors je pense depuis on veut
sur les deux je pense qu'on sacrifiait à
laquelle wec là que tout la bouche page
france un genre cabaye des 5 es ce que
tu manges ben je mange d'un pion et j'ai
un plan passé la paire de fous les cases
noires et ce serait des gros jeux
compenser des atouts en derrière donc
être servi à l'arrêt en fait ouais parce
que parce que le gouverneur tan claude
aubert ouais c'est ça donc là du coup
ses pulsions camier qui est très facile
pour les marins d'un match gasquet
largage est ce un troisième je pose mon
quatrième position écrasante cas ding
avec les noirs je pense qu'il en a gagné
une sur ussel on va voir s'ils arrivent
à compris nation davantage sur cette
parcelle va bien ça semble quand même
il ya une minute 18 en fait jacques en
jeu tant il a ramené son cavalier tuân
nakamura qui joua défensif comme ça
il sera aux
décideurs des sources de 18 ans fait
pareil la salle il faut qu'il la gagne
et le soutien de partis oppositionnels
abba mais comme d'autres en fait dans ce
match en terme de qualité de jeu pour
l'instant digue nous régale franchement
il y aura bien un excellent niveau de
jeu il ne manque que le finish pas
buyema l'otan et il a du mal à terminer
qu'il est mal de temps
caraquet ce qui fait qu'à vih 3 à ses
atours franchement il
ya je crois bien joué dans quatre sites
on voit qui
secoue la tête sans arrêt il a moins
agréable à d'abord l'emploi donc la
laisser là tout comme on vous l'avait
dit oui il ya du foot pro f38 fou ou 3
qui arrive échec qui peut faire très
très mal
vous prendre trois grands il y aura des
matches à matt est sûr d'en prendre adam
échec roy l'a aidé à matt lala samat de
partout mais
enfin karim l'ordinateur donne que le
meilleur ou cm2 pour vous comprenez un
petit peu la difficulté la position et
la camorra abandonne
et après cela on aura droit à une passe
de co2 de pose et de pardon donc fatou
ne part pas ce qu'ils voulaient partir
reste encore cinq minutes
tu auras droit ton petit un petit cadeau
alors avis quand c'est la position sa
sélection qui a été beaucoup beaucoup
joué un
bon papa dans ce match mais c'est hyper
connue en gros les blancs davantage
d'espacé terrain mais tour être échangé
au final et c'est assez assez de bonnes
chances de lyon sa pollution d'égalité
mais on joue en reste principalement sur
les zones a et b1 qui vont s'ouvrir
ces cyber attaques sylvia toi
salue
bien nocturne yes
naqaba non parce que va du coup il ya le
score illégal
bassim smac a mené de trois points ou
quoi il aurait pu faire passer mais la
lie après l'intérêt en fait moi il joue
pour quelque temps encore confiant sur
le fait qu'il va raser en bullet
non queyras amorim et médine quattro qui
s'accrochent qui fait un très beau match
et
c'est cool de voir ça parce que quand
elle un sens en off je parlais un peu
avec ses amis tout à l'heure avant le
début du match et je lui disais que je
pensais que le score allait être
écrasante pour nakamura je pensais et ça
me pensais pas à penser s'adapte au sol
est donc pour l'instant pas il a raison
moi je pensais que j'aurais à peu près à
égalité jusqu'au bullet c'est pas un
avis très très étonnant mais ouais ouais
c'est vrai mais
moi je pensais qu'il allait être plus
plus fort que ça d'accord
mais au final on voit bien que ding en
fait il est meilleur des chèques donc il
arrive à rien montré sa cependant mes
parties
[Musique]
dinia numéro trois mondial et avant
l'arrivée du gros bide c'était de très
loin le rival le plus dangereux de kara
scène était en pleine ascension
les pâtes les 2800 il avait dit
générosité quand on a déjà parlé de 100
parties on le voyait vraiment tous comme
le futur ginger de quercia et de kovy
delahaye au pire moment pour dim il y
avait plein de quarantaine pour les
candidats et du coup ça a complètement
stoppé son élan depuis galère un peu et
a plus trop de tournois il aime pas mais
sur internet
ça reste un joueur hyper hyper fort
alors voix doc voytek pardon je ne sais
pas parce que
tu as tout c'est moi qu'il m'écoute
imbattable aussi je sais pas c'est pas
du tout ce qui se passe
en fait je ne m'entends pas quand je
parle
c'est ouf c'est pas son problème c'est
toujours stouff entre à vous le savez
facile pour vous
est-ce que dean quel effet qualité non
il n'a pas encore vachement qu'il a
participé au grand regret en suisse et
est d'une bourde
du nom de
non il n'a pas une envie n'a rien il a
été finaliste même avant mais j'avais
perdu contre contre radjabov en finale
oui et puis nos jours du coup oui mais
du coup il va participer au grand prix
et puis elle part à khalifa une cure à
deux places les places seront chères
les places sont chères pour maxime où
déjà il est d'ailleurs adding la
question les autres principaux
concurrents mais je pense qu'il y aura
un peu tout le monde alors radio avait
déjà qualifié mais y aura seulement
great chauhdry acquis une erreur à
laquelle étaient
difficiles il a été en finale de la
coupe du monde ah pardon si j'ai une ode
à effectivement
bon en vrai c'est surtout de dix minutes
choc après ça dépendra du groupe avec 15
jours arrivent et puis ça peut être
n'importe qui ont aussi pu drame
surprise parmi tous les joueurs il y
aura beaucoup de 2700 donc
absolue
par damas huit
donc plus en plus pour les noirs denses
à la
ferme plus pour les noirs mais rappelons
bien là aussi il faut demeurer calmes
fils en tout cas c'est moins fou il a de
quoi nourrir pour le tour la torah c'est
le seul enchaînement aurait cinq ans
mais
on sent que les compensations les
cavales qui peut arriver là
ah fat en sont aussi comme aux
fourchettes picavet les baies 5 avec un
petit à 4 chaussures un cavalier genre
tourbe et sert par exemple à 4 67 ans y
ont travaillé ces êtres qui doivent
arriver aussi tôt c'est celle qui peut
arriver aussi même temps b3 activer les
pièces oui mais je pense que c'est à peu
près équilibré non mais il ya des
compensations pour le pion pour
l'audition ce montant des aides de
retard la pendule caméra donc ça c'est
un peu une journée a vu plein de fois
que quand il était retranché dans ses
dernières secondes il est en difficulté
ça c'est le gros problème de d'inga dans
ce match on sait qu'il est ce qu'il est
un petit peu lent dans ce match dans ses
cales ans lena cabaye est sans pitié
et depuis tous les matchs intéressants
de notaire ou la pas les stats mais
l'impression quand même que les noirs
score très très bien me demande si les
noirs sont pas devant même mais c'est
très possible
très possible c'est parce que dans
quatre ans qu'il allait blanc déjà
repris il ya eu beaucoup de nuls aussi
donc beaucoup de miel mais revoit les
images à voir les blanches
ce niveau là très rare même assez 14
comme si c'était attention la tour
sans filtre quand même mais bon qu'est
décide sert pas à grand chose je me
moque moi je l'aurais fait quel est ce
que ces cours et par dan aussi je pense
pas très bon je sais pas c'est de faire
des menaces trop tard donc pas besoin de
ça il faut ici d'être y avait de l'amour
à trois canaux des résines mon adjoint
qui est
donc de 5 avec une fourche et changement
j'ai apprise prise prise
à sa victoire aisée que celle ci
ait eu cette fois c'est l'idée de qu'il
a récupéré son tour mais il va perdre à
troyes et tours b 3 je pense et fait
clouer un il se fait court et voit
encore plus fort ça c'est de la part de
naka tactiquement il toujours affûté wen
a qu à l heure
juste oriola qu'avait le bébé un réseau
il ya ding ding ding la bande non non ça
joue sajou en cavale et v8 l'aja l'a
rapporté le vélo f3 qu'avaient les babes
vers la qualité et du police
là ça va être perdu bon il peut encore
défendre un petit peu même la sienne à
la légion il est apte ou pas croire que
l'artiste dans je ne sais pas il
s'attendait pas à ce que le roi il a un
code qu'il a pris vous verrez que
c'est que ça s'est mal passé
mais après tu sais qu'il reste des gens
malades armes sinon il y avait 1 4
contres 3 passes défendre blazy avait
battu nancy les mandatures f7 squat de
noix mais un brocoli et bien sûr après
l'arrière glavany russie si on peut
faire deux fourchettes d'accueil à
droite se promener fourchette aussi
ouais mais là ça leur thème
qu'il a quand même s'amplifier non je
pense qu'il ya un pion plus mais un cap
et de relief ça que je te vantes
champion est aussi jugé
françois hollande est là il est revenu à
peine voilée la liant à qui il n'y a pas
tout voir ici là il ya des chaises
champions c'est pas qu'il y ait un
optionnel
c6 des cinq tours troyes je fais ça
c'est un sage m'enrage 6 à bien jouer ça
mais ça c'est l'idée en fait il ya
peut-être là sauvé timide devant la
justice et défendra bec et ongles à deux
secondes
macaque est pas content ça que réactive
la sorte s'ils tombent pas ouais là est
ce qu'il peut me l'a gagnée ou perdue
dans la gagne et ça sera quand même
rendre à vienne il a quand même des
films pendant la seconde guerre
moi j'avoue je répare avec les noires de
l'appareil de couleur c'est sûr qu'il ya
une des six
d'un quart d'heure ça y est
ces dames
n'ont même pas matelas
bien car il est mort de rire laquelle
est mort d'où il
s'est passé quoi on va regarder un peu
après ce qu'on a pressé la pause 1
d'après cette partie on regardera
rapidement il ya eu une crise grecque
ils ont repris juste revenu à la partie
précédente pour voir un peu ce qui s'est
passé
donc il ya eu un canal et des six
cellules porte je pense qu'il a fait
exprès puis vous pouvez le faire tomber
jeudi l'ap à la promotion au torrent
d'armes le temps qui passe la ville va
tomber mais je sais pas motion est
obligé de continuer un et là du coup
comment on y aviez avec enora tendre
avec les drôles de dames est ensuite
parce que
ce n'est pas si simple avec 12 secondes
je pense qu'on met de la dame en
en septième rang gênant pour faire un
échec avec le roi après tu vas je pense
dames c'est cette doit gagner
dans ces sept là se croisent ici c'est
de
savoir si j'ai mon ordinateur
[Musique]
s'est pas c'est pas si facile d'un ski
lara terre
non parce que nakamura ils étaient
brûlés avaient vu une seconde j'ai
presque à cause d'un
17 seul coup date 17 et dames c est de
voir c'est pas la différence dom cette
marche pas
khattabi être son arrivée la dame était
protégé par la tour dimanche prochain je
pensé ok c'est bon tu sais où tu nous
tiens apparemment c'est quoi la nuance
dame 17
ça c'est rigolo ce qu'il a fait cap
d'agde à la prise de commandes
damages quoi alors pourquoi de ce côté
là ok ok enfin écoute
avec le one tu viens de la scène
l'anticiper c'est impossible c'est
impossible à trouver une seconde c'était
bien trop de la part de nakata a failli
autant
mal en quoi au caire sont partis en
pause les gars on va nous aussi vous
vous de même type dash de de pub on
revient dans d'ici trois quatre minutes
a tout de suite
[Musique]
nous sommes revenus les gars par sami
qui n'est pas revenue encore assez bon
mais la caméra avait
donc digue n'est pas là mais il va
arriver un légat peu de patience qu'on
va reprendre ce matin dans quelques
instants donc je vais enlever cette
partie donc le score à 17 7 pour
l'instant de cette moitié de match on a
fait vraiment chaud des marques et
d'ailleurs on a fait une heure et demie
de cinq pilules et une demi heure mais
plus 35 minutes de trois plus une donc
il nous reste 25 minutes de trois plus
une maintenant et ensuite une demi-heure
de blitz de deux blocs pardon donc on
encore une heure de match et le score
pour les sens et de 7,7 donc égalité
parfaite
avec très peu de très peu de deux
parties décisives et d'ailleurs savoir
qu'il a un côté hyper intéressante on va
où nakamura se prend 15 avec les six
et il ne le voit pas parce qu'il avait
la gueule il la commence à
chanter ah bah il a vraiment fait
d'écouter de parole de la star il était
toujours notre département la ville a
tenté en 10 ans et d'art diable c'est
pas moi je pense qu'il allait bien
je pense qu'il a eu de la chance tout
deux se sent pas si pire que ça ça a
repris les gars alors bon je veux pas la
partie pas pourquoi
attention à ne pas qui tu n'as qu'à moi
je me ramasse tout en fait je pourrais
équipe n'a qu'à mondiale ont sincèrement
la dernière action
et pourquoi pas jouer la terre de
m'expliquer
singh la gâche pas le vent jaune et
je vais actualisé jeudi avoir un
problème voilà la partie a repris je
vais quand même leur suivre non c'est
bon je suis un petit bug de connexion
et on voit pas du coup la tête de notre
meeting
ta scache
pourquoi digue est parti chez moi
dans le livre on va pas dîner en deux
d'accord
mais caméra qui saute et digne qui est
parti dans le live je ne vois plus
les
transformant en droit de désigner pour
doha l'explication non je le vois
surtout demain
c'est chez moi donc je vais là je vais
me remettre à il aurait pu leur venue ok
donc je sais pas ce que s'est passé
dit le magicien
alors qu'il nous lance une petite
attaque à base de hache un k way sur le
groupe blanc
est-ce que tu n'as qu'à il a bloqué à
cash 4 non
je faire c'est quand même ça donne quand
même beaucoup de cases quasiment à un
canthare ouais alors h4 ici moi je moi
j'aime beaucoup les normes qui plus que
deux positions a comme d'argent filliter
dira mais dans ce match j'ai
l'impression que vraiment c'est noir qui
prennent avantage dès l'ouverture à
chaque fois
incroyable ouais rien ne change grassi
ont pu l'être ça évolue
alors dit mme christiane berton pointe
donc il avancé jusque là qu'il a
reprises l'objet de l'échangé voilà il a
peut-être peut faire un point bas de 2 j
six rangées cette tâche lui pourquoi pas
pour attaquer le monde la connaît
nakai jamais content ak il est hyper
expressif quand il quant à gameiro en
finir là
qui grimace le plus bas soit il parle
tout seul et nakai crime à
trois avec des rois j'ai deux tours h 1
alors
contrairement à timbi comment qui la caf
et le plan que j'avais envisagé pour
bing
ouais donc du coup voir il aimerait
mettre le roi je documente châteauroux
un champ et attaquer mais la cavaille
cinq attaques le coup je ne peux pas me
permet de donner le vent ou faux trop
important et magnifique
je pense que tu as quand même de
l'avocat marcel là bas moi je préfère
les noirs c'est clair je suis d'accord
qu'il t'a rue de la joie quand même
en pratique c'est quand même mais de
neiges
et laurent blanc est plus faible
on voyait plus faible en 3g 2 j'espère
que tu tombes sur tours un chat un chat
en
rallye 2 si on revient en jce je pense
qu'il va faire courage et ne
le coup logique dont le sait on que je
peux faire tout rachat quand même
courage et de trois chalets à [ __ ] en
plus on prend
quelqu'un qui fait quoi du coup ça vaut
une question et parce qu'en fait c'est
vrai que là
si je bouge mais on fouille légère
reprise prises et des lettres arabes en
coin 3 obtient
ouais parce que l'âge et à ça ça et ça
aussi un est apprécié
au recul et au mien quand tu recules le
fouillis appuyé par foot 38 on prend une
découverte sur le roi qui peut être
problématique
alors là attention mêmes qui emprisonne
la c1 dames 6 est possible sous préfet
aura des échecs aussi avec la tournée
des [ __ ] font attention salaires ont
finalisé au noir
et en plus d'offrir ses collègues
notamment b3 il ya un vis-à-vis en fait
et du coup après fou prend on comprend
qu'elle va les prendre en t4 et check
your head times prend b3 d'arrière où
vous découvert sa voie c'est une double
découverte de jolis un garde temps b3
cela va être une belle gaffe de la part
de la camorra quillan à kauai il est pas
content une fois il parle tout seul il
secoue la tête comme ça
elle atterrit les combats vers une
nouvelle victoire des noirs
ils reprennent la tête
il a joué coillard cuillé son cavalier
pour éviter la prise
ou les atours h2 qui est magnifique
courage du roi proche de la machine
cavalli ac 3 qui a été loupé ce thème at
elle bien qu'il ait 3 3 tomates en
matant quatre tambours
c'est dommage toi je dois était attendu
comme le monstre est rudement bon il a
abandonné convard un palace méthane donc
dinka qui prend leur dean qui prend le
lead donc là vous voyez nakamura qui est
complètement fou tu n'as pas essayer de
voir la suite de la partie et il a
vraiment directement parce qu'il est
mené en fait en quoi il variera pas jour
le times parce qu'il est mené 1 mène
évidemment il faut qu'il se refasse il
veut se refaire donc il a tout intérêt à
ce que ce qui est plus de partir à pied
son orgueil à qui entrent en ligne de
compte aussi ce problème de ces défaites
à chaque fois il s'est quand même et
ceux qui aiment bien marcher dessus là
donc ils ont envie de réagir scam le
tenant du titre
salut amsterdam ou passage et oui arrive
au meilleur des moments le suspense est
toujours là
et où dans la dernière heure de jeu
et digne du coup qui peut peut-être
c'est de faire le break avec les blancs
là ça serait vraiment le moment pour lui
de prendre de l'avancé alors pu l'être
se rapproche peut-être mangé le tube et
cinq ici c'est parce qu'on a tout à
l'heure on a deux c'est plus 5000 fois
bon je vais 5 qui ramène la tour le fou
tu rentres par là et les blancs sont
quand même très très bien appliqué
tomber s'attaque la tour
la dernière fourchette là c'est bien
châtie c'est une fourchette tôt je
compte bien ma cachette
makichuk complètement là qu'il faut j'ai
trois justin non répond à la 83e
8 quel point tu bouges ton fouet
et même dû tomber ainsi l'intermédiaire
atacama les frontons garras trophy là
c'est bien joué c'est précis
il est en train de couler la mine à
kkb db5 et qu'il arrive non mais
regardez des pièces noires la triplette
la plus ridicule de l'histoire à ce que
le pire c'est que sur cavale et b5
bout jusqu'à va les prendre en temps
proche encore une autre fourchette
triste et derrière c'est un cauchemar en
plus cela dingila 2 minutes 20 attendu
cette partie ne peut pas lui échapper
c'est pas possible à ce niveau là ne pas
marquer poindre à l'horizon comme ça
c'est pas un haka des jantes
rcc ding qui l'avons même directes et
abandonnée
et il se complaît l'a86 est complet et
dean qui passeraient deux points
d'avance incroyable coeur [ __ ] j'y
crois pas que le tig et l'empilement des
créer l'exploit dans ce match de là on a
vacillé à quelques déjà des restos
qui n'est pas pareil
mais il a changé la regarder d'al qaïda
arrêté avec son cavalier f3 où il se
faisait défoncé il avait eu quatre
adjoints pour entre guillemets normal
classique il part sur une espagnole je
veux jouer un petit peu de théorie
peut-être prendre un petit avantage avec
les blancs ont causé signe qu'il a
compris qu'il allait finir par perdre le
match la france
well et commencer un mouvement d
ouverture quel plus
normal normal qu'avec des f3 beaucoup
trop défendre qu'attaquer le fou
[Musique]
c'est l'argent du 50 m et le 100 m 5
j'arrive à temps pour défendre le
cavalier un peu limite quand même une
addition salée tenir effectivement f6
peut-être même si certes très bon os 6
et c'est logique regardez notre foule
mais dans une belle diagonale met la
pression sur des deux voilà c'est jouer
j'aime bien les noix encore là il a géré
pendant la majeure
j'ai pas vu
ça souvent tout moisi mais l'activité
finalement
c'est un peu contre le sud de dakar
toujours
sur la défensive
alors est ce qu'on peut continuer à
défendre les pions à prendre de l'espace
comme ça
pour pouvoir plus tard
cavaliers
rien quand même pouvoir sortir mes
pièces quoi espérer at war gun sur des
deux tombe bien c'est pas sans coût pour
mon visage et mes
ccd problème est là mille facettes qui
empêche aussi à 5 ans est un sas et qui
mené à ces deux après le manger autour
des 5 et en plus ça fixe la faiblesse en
raciste peu tard en fin de partie une
grosse faiblesse un champion
dès les noirs une belle activité
c'est le
3-6 6-1 il ya des cases et des 15 chez
les noirs
cavaliers qui l'avenir un look cavalli
pour estimer la prison sont des 5 1
du coup il continue comme à s'activer
avec kovalev 5
ya g4 qui peut partir de ces atouts peu
trop changé car tu
sais jouer parnac acquis en train de
réagir dans son parti et dans la marne à
un marché
l'ablation partielle importante pour lui
si personne n'a cessé antérieur
il a besoin de motiver g5 ilves 1 qui
joue et qu'il va les prendre un grand
fou aux 7 s comprend le f5 derrière ce
qui bougeait cavale et c6 il est en
train de passer ça peut être pas mal
parce que ma crise et si c'est un bep
cap si harry un câble il va offrir et il
domine la le cas l'année la bourse jean
la foule âge et ça ça ça un cavalier par
mois dans cette lettre il est très
précis est très agressif
et belle action à dakar sur cette partie
iv 3 il tente de compliquer 10000 à
raison food et 15 boom ouassou des
cartes c'est joli alors on s'est plantés
par nacarat est ce qui fait la tête la
moitié mais pas content mais je pense
avoir
non ça y est ça y est il est pas content
seuil et tilt bah oui parce que
maintenant ça change mais mais
qu'avaient les baies 3 apparemment il a
raté j'ai promis six ans
il a raté j'ai pris un risque et points
et probablement à m'attaquer à la veille
avait des problèmes et du coup la partie
est complètement relancée maintenant
on va prendre la colonne ne peut-être
vite car la très logique ici d'un dessin
aussi que la dame sera
révélée sur madame b 4 peut-être sa
cavale il peut pleuvoir il faut aussi
dire attends cavaliers le cadre du droit
comment peut peut-être prendre du plomb
du coup c'est ça même cavalier j'aime
bien perturbé katché qui a valu à 4
après je t'aime je t'aime 5 coutellerie
et cavaliers prisca va les prendre câble
et il est très très fort à
un point de moins des cavaliers fois que
nous faut donc en pratique salaires
beaucoup plus facile pour les noirs bas
le fou en fait c'est pas une bonne pièce
parce qu'il est d'ailleurs c'est les
pions de sa couleur donc on va te fous
ainsi on dit fait le mauvais choix six
classes dans ses albums égale
des quatre cavaliers 80 ans dames des 5
ok en fait c'est un clouage donc on va t
il au juste ramener des pièces de ces
bien jouer encore dam des séracs un très
bon coup digne d'un t3 si possible pas
de ce qu'il est un joueur blessé je pars
dit pas que la pression ici à tours 2-1
qui va être joué cavalier leucate qui va
bouger
n'hésite pas vraies
stars courait après
quand même le café noir qui cloue qui
bat c'est ça fout des cas d'eceh team
qui se fige et cloud qui s'est fait
avoir je peux aller ailleurs intel je
peux aller en d3 d2 à faire bizarre bel
et bon je repars tout rire ou te temps
17 d'antarès comme napster
parce qu'en fait si on échange d'une
pièce lourds décidée à la gagne et qu'on
peut être très facilement pour les
banques puisque là avec vous écouter on
va menacer d'échanger les tours et les
dames soit sa place dans l'échiquier ce
qui a pu bien sûr je rejoins du d5
prises les pions qui va filer il ya un
pont plus à cannes pour les blancs et
voilà c'est ça va faire ses quatre des
cinq et nous faut et nous avons gagné la
dîme doit à tout prix garder au moins
une tour sur l'échiquier évidemment
mieux garder les tables il ya des
problèmes ici c'est je crois qu
il ya les appeler chez du coup ils n'ont
pas sur les choses avec une minute
risque de la perdre qu'il avait sacrifié
le cavalier
alors selon son ordinateur tu vois
fabius de ce google
va jouer cette finale il a gagné un
point mais le
le plus rare est trop fort
voici va être dur à arrêter parce qu'on
recueille 10,7 je fous le f2 est en fait
juste ça ça et ça tu veux pas déranger
parce que y'a des fois c'est aussi non
mais c'est ardu en fait mais c'est pas
très très sage ça ça les cavaliers qui
vient je le beauf des cahiers b 8e fois
cette
mlg malgré cette cave et les bouchons
mais bon ok dacca au caire après pour
l'intérêt du match qu'à une cool que
dakar viennent un petit peu oui que
presque intenable que j'aimerais bien
que dean cain un petit peu le large
avant les bullet
pour la gagner c'est la scène notamment
au moins de bois
et c'est vrai qu'on a vu on a vu digne
qui avait un point ou d'avant cependant
cette partie 1 sur mac à un incroyable
et ça c'est vrai que
de voir que n'a quasi pas numéro 1 c'est
vraiment
s combien de temps là dans ce segment il
reste dix minutes même pas ouvertement
lignage différent moins deux parties
ouais 2 201 une c'est sûr et je pense
voix 12 c'est sûr qu'ils en noir
probablement deux parties après 30
minutes donc une plus sinon on aurait
une petite pause entre les deux
qui restent d'encore deux parties je
pense au blitz une petite pause 5
minutes et après l'oreille du bien
meilleur de bullet et c'est ce qui est
le plus excitant un bullet 1 quand on
voit le match commencera sa visite ça va
plus vite c'est hyper intéressant puis
ça c'est vraiment ça va très très vite
quoi c'est impressionnant le bulletin
il y aura doublette quoi qu'il arrive un
oui en fait c'est quoi qu'il arrive le
match dur dur
3h30 une troisième ça c'est pas un match
c'est pas un membre en fonction d'un tel
score on s'est un temps défini ouais je
joue une heure et demie en cinq nuls
ensuite tu fais une heure en trois plus
une puis tu fais une demi heure en trois
plus en pension peu importe qui se passe
avant après si jamais à l'aise tout ça
et bien ses qualités leila ya des
partages mais
bon ça c'est rare qui départage les
trois heures de match c'est très rare
mais ça a failli arriver avec maxime
contre mika renard et avec et avec le
dernier match sous contre ça rit ça se
terminer avec 15 14 dans les vingt
points d'écart dans les deux matchs et
pour l'instant on est à 9,8 donc on
n'est pas à l'abri encore que d'avoir un
des possibles
alors est-ce que digne il met la
pression avec les blancs j'ai
l'impression qu'au discours est plus d
espace
à l'orée de l'été partage vous en fait
tu as
ta quatre parties de bullet
et à l'esprit qu'une partie 6 encore
égalité y aura une seule partie
armageddon
tortora un joueur qui aura cinq minutes
et
avec les blancs avec les noirs pardon et
le gens qu'à six minutes à l'eiblen ya
pas d'un crémant c'est comme ça et en
cas de nul et bien aux gens qui a cinq
minutes donc lé noir gagne le match ces
histoires de pâtes et j'aime et je crois
qu'on a eu jusqu'à l'armageddon
ensuite je ne suis pas sur moi j'habite
chez moi j'avais vu un armageddon qui
était arrivé au chocolat de france
adultes je crois que c'était c'était
bakwa contre freyssinet froid et vain
pour kigali autant alors qu'il était
foutu
pour le titre de champion de france bah
ouais bon après il a eu le mérite énorme
en bonne partie dans tout ça mais après
c'est le format qui veut ça je trouve
que ça nous mettre un raid l'armageddon
dans un camp ya autant d enjeux c'est
beaucoup c'est sais c'est cruel 1 mais
bon c'est
comme ça bah en fait un moment donné il
faut mettre une limite en fait tant que
cet infini
moi j'avais vu une fois je vais jamais
arbitré son contrat régional jeunes et
il y avait des partages comme ça il n'ya
pas d'armageddon et lé et les joueurs
prennent les deux jeunes arrêtés pour
une place qualificative
ils avaient dit qu'ils avaient joué
pendant
deux heures pour se départager au blitz
est horrible horrible moi je vais
arrêter massacre j'en ai marre des
grains franchement les deux les deux
mérités de la qualif
ouais mais tu vois c'est cruel pour les
pour des gosses tous les deux mérité la
qualif et tous étaient ravis de leur
donner le bourdon
gt gt pareil principalement j'étais je
faisais un stage pour être arbitre
justement son mandat donc moi je prends
une décision je te la
mets là je pense qu'après le règlement
c'est à ce niveau là pour des enfants
qu'un ange éduqué comme ça je vais
pendant deux heures
ils ont vraiment jeu très très longtemps
la remise des prix a été décalée de deux
heures parce que oui
horrible
on a changé d'époque battre métal ça
c'est sûr
et
là on voit qu'il y avait deux puces pour
ding mais il ya encore des compensations
sur sur le gaz mans et à boire surtout
après de cet échange là je considère de
la part d'un casque ce n'est plus pour
leur poser donc c'est de plus en plus
beau être très dur a valorisé puisque le
foot carte blanche des blancs mais
débloquer dernière session et les noirs
qu'on trouve toutes les cases bord donc
ici je suis même pas sûr que les lensois
sont sûrement dire mieux mais
d'un compliqué en tout et en pratique
alors ce qu'il faut dire c'est que en
faut que l'on opposé
enfin en fait les fous composé phare vos
attaques en fait la grue de l'attaqué du
coup bas le football noir en restait
très bien placé le fond blanc est mal
placée du coup il ya plein de
compensation et si jamais nord arrive à
bien s'activer il pourrait peut-être
poser des problèmes aux blancs tout même
un jour être mieux pour l'instant c'est
pas ben c'est pas le cas ils t'aiment
deux pions de plus ça c'est quand même
beaucoup l'un et les cases blanches sont
bien protégés les gars moi aussi y a pas
de quoi s'alarmer du tout mes amis ce
sont des changes pour faire décroître
bègles et fo a pas de vrai nom sauf si
la loi arrive à s'activer voilà mais
normalement à
devoir faire un blocus mais attention
parce que là maintenant peut-être que
les blancs s'activent en premier babacan
au tango c'est loana ex les pièces
billardon ce qu'il a fait voilà
franchement ce qu'il veut c'est de
rentrer en rang à 2 par là mais moi
j'étais entouré ferait de façon qui
tient la baraque j'ai capté un lien
c'est l'exemple et c'est bien mais j'ai
cassé les banques attaque garantie va
allonger franchise
je donne pas trop bon pas cher de la
peau de yack alain tourret tu défends f2
et hashtag qui arrive
faucon et c'est aussi 2 mais la surprise
la fuite
ça c'est une menace
islamiste d'amd 8
juin que je pense
et réfléchie nakaya plus que 17 secondes
quel âge 5 1 sans réfléchir je ferais
bien celle ci et là j'ai pu leur donner
vie
j'aurais pu manger c'est un coup dur car
même s'il a raté sa gagner donc nous
sommes là non mais ok ou celle là il me
dans l'hyper évident
qu'il fallait avoir des dommages et ben
tiens à avoir trois fonds d'avancés tagi
tranquille il voulait faire ça titre
pour gagner pour avoir une position en
versant sans risque mais au final il a
oublié qu'à la fin il faut pas défendre
[Musique]
f2i n'ont pas dit ce qu'ils ont peu de
temps tous les deux fait voir peut-être
que je peux réussir à ramener un truc
droit local à tourves arrivant en bk
toute façon est un portage sera le tube
et si sa devancière
donc ça ça risque de faire annuler donc
les deux joueurs ont 20 secondes à la
pendule il reste 2 800 dans le match
donc si vous dire que a priori aura une
une dernière partie comment les
agréments c'est dans cette carence
qaïda et daté
mais ya pas mal
d'infos
pour la
pokernews ils ont puni le saint thomas
je pouvais refaire le break ding on l'a
ratée pour confier 6 c'est probable
ouais vraiment donc dans la partie de
cette heure de ce cette portion donc
avec toujours plus sain pour ding ding
qu'elle est noire abdoulaye parce que
démarre généralement ces mamans les
auteurs de ce matin maintenant qu'il
sera même arthur
normal comme l'espagnol s'est pas
caractère il a réussi à avoir
la chance la dalle
donc là du coup n'a qu'à doigts et ce
qui est parti pour pas se mettre dans le
mal n'a égalisé way et donc
moi je suis pour ding ce parti là bas ça
mettra dans un tueur un petit peu
d'enjeu
et que et que dire la bulle est faux il
faudrait bien sage or c'est intéressant
parce que les bulles de services de
match là c'est pour dean cain
franchement uma kamouraska même son gros
point fort le bullet par rapport à ding
et c'est vrai que je pense que
ce serait vraiment intéressant mais
c'est plus de reading pour voir ce qui
se passe 90 lots dit combi là tu
regardes et
voir si on peut voir son amant belote
ça reste décent c'est pas mal mais n'a
4400 donc sans 1440 il a même eu la nuit
3550 un regard java raison profil
[Rires]
il joue bien ou que l'on y joue bien je
joue bien
combien de me laisse songeur aminé rock
mais ça peut dépendre des fois de la
stratégie de match par exemple saut où
trône et face à une vue qu'ils avaient
de la vence bas au lieu d'abandonner
quand j'étais foutu les mêmes jusqu'au
match je les ai trouvés ou sarah course
les bombes deux parties
score est serré les deux joueurs vont
jouer normalement donc je sais pas après
en 30 minutes des parties depuis le plus
sud
combien ça en fait en général sus je
passe donne une idée de tête parce que
tu dirais qu une part 6
design on
n'en manque sa voix que ça
je pense qu'il va y avoir une partie
dure environ quatre minutes
par exemple socar wanna
die a vu 7e je crois ouais je crois que
je crois que tu as tu as dû
entre 8 et 10 martys france ok
faut plus de voir que l'autre quart et
arian dans l'autre demi finale il y
avait eu
[Musique]
à 8 10 voire à 8
19 parties en sachant que cela est fait
traîner coire donc je pense qu'il faut
bien d'avoir le dixième club
alors qu'avaient les baies 3 aucun la
poche depuis quatre ans peut faire donc
un
signal négatif va tomber de 5 c'est un
coup un seul schoren
je peux défendre aussi manger h2k et 17
tu peux rapport d'un cavalier prend
qu'elle va les prendre et f4 qui propose
quoi comme alternative acquis et les
sept j'en ai pas ok la pièce je vois pas
de trou noir qui va les prendre en mains
des pro et f4 que m'ont toujours fait
disponible et inquiets bref quatre dames
mais aussi ses trois juges de l'émission
poirier ouais mais tu sais pas quand
même je sais pas trop
l'homme et sa carrière us 5 haïm et
welsh bas des contextes
bon bah du coup dit mais un trou plus
non ouais
donc le noir sont une nouvelle fois très
très bien ouais la perte de fou à
tourner plus pour le pion des caps vous
voyez de tomber mais c'est pas sûr
puisque la tour derrière on vise avec la
dame peut-être juste un car elle
baissait de fouet quasiment car mr
manger et après minuit avec la terre de
foot n'a été plus facile si on passait
et des pions qui est pas encore qui est
peintre à part du lion des quatre global
il ya une fois qu'il sera mangé il y
aura une découverte ailleurs à une
pression de visas vis sur la sur la la
colonne des donc c'est ça serait
compliqué mehdi qui sont comme à l'otan
ban qui joue plus vite la bonne nuit
âgée pas de choses bonne nuit à
l'excellent
d'image mais p6 finalement il me jouer
ces cinq enquêtes
c'est ça qui veut garder son pion son
pion passé presque oublié la calculer et
ce qui se passe sur la prise en d4 ouais
visuellement ça fait peur
l'egypte et trois blessés cinq j'imagine
on va peut-être avoir des photos
couleurs opposées
en plus m ces dernières attaques et
ses prises
cavaliers futon qu'il veut cavaliers
aussi si le c5 aussi ouais mais la scala
bungie pas manger parce que je suis deux
fois tubes we garde son compte s'il
arrive à garder son compte il est très
bien ce cavalier des formes aussi depuis
mais aussi de prix ce qui est un peu
passé là c'est normal d'en manger manger
et donc c'est qu'à une son jeu contre je
lui en sais pas ce qu'il veut être créée
dix mille ans voit son pion des il
pousse le pion des exactement ils ont
poussé des ailes c'est archi noir mais
il faut que je découvre vite l'un il
faut qu'ils jouent vite soit ces
passants pour encore joey vie des deux
ok ça passe ce qui enrichira obtenir ce
qu
en dit qu'il est bien bloquée sur
casablanca
j'arrive à des pièces c'est un train de
tabasser un tour de trop un jour donc il
a mangé alliés prg en d2 et qu'il était
entré ce qu'ils ont fait il ya des coups
à
savoir ça semble ardue à son malheur dur
il ya vingt secondes pour les noirs
iphone précise jusqu'au bout d'âme ces
deux hommes je sais pas idée car
il t'a de la pièce à 7 waouh je suis
comme en plus rien villar à coups de
jets le food en bâches
à un million
ouais à 1000 voire interdit ces six
après d'entamer cette théâtre d'un
brigandage de pia dimanche marc planus
pour les noirs ouais et d'abus de biens
la gauche alors ont sélectionné des
pièces
qui va changer des pièces équivalent
soeur comme la turquie qui a pris dans
des câbles doit être pas gagnante la
finale de cavalia les gagnants que ça
c'est sûr voilà j'ai quand même amené ce
qui va la gagner ça c'est pas sûr non
moi je fais ces six là quelques semaines
le site du coup ils n'ont rien à voir
comme ça on va essayer de
3d c'est ce qui arrive à bout de
tous passé un an c'est finalement même
si elles ont des cavaliers
7 p
500 ou mépris c'est un bon technicien
normalement
baies 5 pouces et 5
il joue tous mes coups dit la mairie
erin pour le joueur
la victoire en poche
c'est son credo et ouais c'est très bien
grosse technique de ding ouais il se
rapproche maintenant il va peut-être
donner son feu vert mais pour aller
manger cavale et des cartes c'est un
coût puisque f4 par exemple si nous nous
sommes vraiment très de roanne a dit
ok il faut qu'ils la gagnent c'est la
digue il faut former les crackers
pas les messins n'ont non plus j'étais
pas fameux les genres et tous les pions
arrête de changer comme moi je tremble
cinq ans le cas des quatre îles aïssa
menadi qui est des cinq échecs qu'est-ce
qui fait prier répète pourquoi
il avait à faire nul comme
c'est bon il a défendu maka il va encore
s est tournée mais nous sommes fiancés
de simplifier
l'échangé tous les pions
ses rimes ça à faire annuler du coup
ça a été complétée manga yodimi
il a vu dieu il avait du temps
ak il a très bien défendu encore une
fois très grosses ressources c'est un
toit ya cette brique
5e plusieurs parties que que ding se
fait ça fait un petit peu are back et en
fin de partie un manque un petit peu
retravaillé quand il et quand il m'a
l'otan il manque de précision et c'est
ce qui me fait un peu peur dans la bulle
est un qui arrive mais il n'arrive plus
à martin 3 points d'avancé ouais
donc tu as ding et qui qui qui prend de
l'avant cela enfin qui calment un peu en
avance pour commencer la bulle est donc
c'est quand même pas mal mais on va voir
ce que ça donne en tout cas une moins
belle la cave et il a gardé plus de en
blitz ce qui était je pense inattendu
donc voir mois
donc on va voir bon on vous le passez
une petite page de pub et on la dernière
ici si d'ici cinq petites minutes
verdict rester là ce qu'il est tard
jusque là il faut finir en plus
populaire et le plus sympa c'est le plus
sympa donc rester là et on revient tout
de suite a tout de suite
[Musique]
à
et nous sommes de nouveau
reparti pour cette dernière portion
depuis l'ère justement c'est
donc avec ding qui est à +1
donc aux manches mois s'appuie sur un
balai première voie est super
intéressante yes pour le coup il en
parle droit de
mal commencer si l'on perd 2 ou 3 y ait
derrière nakai d'or
8 lourd il ya commencé environ
je vais commencer à danser chanter
mais il faut qu' il faut que ding
commence à gagner un petit peu des
premières pour de cas
reste juste dans les premières parties
pour montrer qu'il ya clairement un un
enjeu donc là où on dit que c'est pas un
charlot franchement pour ce masque
laquelle montré pas mal de fois beaucoup
de partis qui qu'il dominait donc papa
jacques renard le score regarde après
vingt-cinq où il a plu dix minutes à la
pendule donc il a réussi à tout de suite
essayé de se mettre dans un rythme de
jouer tempo
changer du blitz essayer de jouer
bientôt celui que je dis sabres commence
à naître
et les tanks ça y est ils tentent ok
donc qu'elle est un
gros point noir quand même avec la
structure cases blanches ont réussi
qu'un méchant explique anne montchamp
c'était quand même la mauvaise presse
donc une position où les blancs peuvent
amasser un peu tranquillement peut-être
alain cavalier en f3 pour essayer de
ramener tard une pièce de 5 donc genre
ça ça à ça ça peut être une possibilité
une seule colonne verte ici elle est
contrôlée par la dame blanche forcément
un avantage de l'imposition de plus
c'est aussi un avantage des espaces des
cases pour les pièces mineurs puis les 4
c marc y avait des fuites mais je
pouvais manger et manger une un pion je
pense qu'il a été raté par les joueurs
bref car ça gagner un jambon
hockey cavaliers la ville
il peut bien le torturer un
récit où il a subi
mais là je mets un cavalier tu veux le
cavalier le b3 en f3 pour elle entre 5
et après tu vas t'appeler pioncer
sissako jordan v6 ça a l'air d'être très
très dur pour pour les mauriciens les
trois pièces blanc dominent les trois
pièces noires à partir de là ça va
compliquer notre position et blanc tout
le temps de jeu pour améliorer devenu
monter le roy quitte à petit préparer
des ruptures de pro
donc ici se doit être gagneront
l'impulsion au rescrit un pion passé qui
essaient 5 alors que les scores
elle aurait pour l'instant c'est ainsi
de la croire quand même province neuf
étoiles de mougins l'europe a passé un
ied roi peut être 1h28 maintenant il y
aura toujours aussi sens là c'est quand
même compliqué tu voyais à la cyclassics
de la gagne pour son corps surtout en
bien sûr mais pour the black amour et
dakar plus maka qui défend tous la
perfection quasiment prise prison break
trois à l'ailé où j'habite pas réfléchir
m'a dit comme ça
ça c'est dit mme x ni la première partie
bullet ce serait quand même assez énorme
ça serait énorme
f4e 2
il veut faire blocus un d'un car je
pense ouais non n'aura plus d'entrées un
sommet sur les cases
et le cavalier un doigt et pour toutes
les cases des cavaliers ce qu'avaient
les montreuillois
parce que c'est possible de progresser
pour mettre un terme à nos cinq bons
mètres sud en australie siens et tout le
monde comme pour continuer à faire parce
que tu sais pas où aller il a mangé ses
5 et efficaces au tir ok ça ça va gagner
à tout prix les gagnants il à public se
cond à cette option de police avec le
canal hier il avait encore plein de
choses
encore un pion gratuit
nakai est pas content là c'est vraiment
la gueule il a gardé tout près le
mouvement baptisé
ok f4 rahman le rough activement ou
cavaliers aussi il suffit de prendre une
fourchette tu perds un des pions mais
le cavalier tu vois il a faim il a fait
un super boulot en 2008 mais maintenant
il fallait vraiment insolite c'est
marvel avait réussi à enclencher la
marche avant bourse cette fois elle
qu'avec il y en a six ou f6 bond des
charges comme ça et si cette arrivée et
s'est terminée à boisredon dis bien la
première partie et on voit que dj de
gagner fin du point et louvain en temps
une partie avait dû reconnaître que
dingila un vélo en fait
enfin il a joué quasiment jamais
ambulants fatigue et toux qui sont
vraiment bullet et
et donc du coup son nez en fait c'est
pas grand chose
puisque fin tu prends une partie ça veut
dire que tous jouent pas en fait le pas
beaucoup et que du coup
1 3300 ouais mais 28 points
quand tu vas un joueur
bien meilleurs que toi surtout surface
comme tu gagne 12 points c'est le max
donc l'a28
ça montre que tu juges mais en fait
on a vu qu en bullet ma carrière est
terminée comme d'habitude sur ses
fientes 14 il a abandonné le 4 qui
l'avait envoyé pour les deux derniers
elle trois fûts saint clair partie sur
du g3 du b3
c'est d'ailleurs ce savine qu'il est
maintenant là il a beaucoup je celle-là
contre guy en fait la même plein dixième
constructeur
qui avait démarré un peu sonné un
badigeon joueurs impeccable franchement
il a un niveau de jeu qui est juste qui
est juste je construis quoi revoir très
vite s'il est correct mais en fait c'est
parti joue propre et la serbie et la
différence un peu plus de maka qui
souvent mal et qui arnaquent alors que
ding vraiment un jeu propre il vous
déposer chaque cas
non vraiment c'est sait
rien à dire est-ce qu'il va la tenir
celle ci avec les noirs commencent à
être calme mal autant pour la pression
ah si facile de trouver un plan ici pour
lui d'un petit promu aix format a5 tuner
fond du bar sont voués 4 mais qui peut
se faire chasser par sept rois des rois
alors qu'il y avait des b2k et 17 km à
la quête on voit les cases noires en b6
d'amérique normal pour empêcher la de
s'installer ici en tête le t4 pour
revenir s'installer en défense à cinq
pour être possible
mais dans l'esprit un très bon joueur on
joue pour jouer pour gr5 ou g5 ça c'est
la position que l avantage de lens qui
peuvent attaquer sur les 2e et l'a fait
il ya un petit peu tu as ton d un tour
c'est un il il s'est très vite
il a compris que
j'attends à toi je suis solide ding a
compris que la ce voilà qu'il fallait à
tant de cavaillé 7 3 on revient tout
cavalier en deux et dès 4h un génie joue
tous les coups de la carte mais sa
b2 b6 et c 5 un jour j'ai encore passé
mais dans la tension ok attention c'est
un peu parce tour des huiles peut-être
tradition et chaude
attendent bien que cavaler la main pour
24 culan bessette
avoir 6 passes et 4
des 7 arrive pas les ondes et 5 et du
coup valence à balard comme très
prometteur pour les plans leur
ordonne c3
comme continue et ziaya
ils accueilleront les ondes attendue
lundi ni franchement de fer fouet à ce
que j'ai à dire quoi profondeur il va
les manger à 4
viennois en fait arriverait à peu près
réseau
en bessin réflexion granby 5 mais ma du
coup les blancs wes a pris trop de temps
et au final les blancs vous finir par
échanger des pièces et avoir à apprendre
plus c'est tranquille il n'y a pas trop
il ya par contre j'en ai fait un faux à
4 il en veut plus c'est une très bonne
partie la plage retrouver un cas qui
fait une très bonne partie là
il ya très précis la vague et process is
joe et tactique qu'on veuille encore un
pion de la deux purs bas sellier s'est
terminée dans le x j achète des noirs
qui n'a pas joué de la partie comme
s'ils voulaient qu'une pièce de monnaie
et ben non il suffit de mentionner
bourse à bruxelles il a supprimé en
recoller à -11 1
donc il reste encore 21 minutes donc tu
vois on n'a fait que deux partis l'un en
9 minutes 1 donc ça
ça va quand même
donc est indienne tours 8
avec dams et de septembre où se trouve
en juin généralement dans le secteur de
tours vite
c'est un peu bizarre de faire d'options
quito dans l'east indienne c'est pas un
truc à que tu vois souvent mais mais ok
c'est un peu dégueulasse qui fait en
général entre des cases des six pour les
cavaliers qui peuvent arriver très très
vite
le tour des six lotos rondelle j'aime
pas du tout ce que c'est un cadre à
cette ouverture
peut-être que je comprends rien mais à
quoi c'est compliqué c'est compliqué
et au passage je vois que dans le chatt
sa dérive un peu notre ami à dessus me
0,7 ce n'est pas content des
commentaires il peut aller se coucher
sur une autre chaîne sur chaise comme
international ya aucun problème il en
faut pour tous les goûts et les objets
de répondre sa négativité s'il en tout
cas ça lui plaît pas on peut avec cette
parenthèse clause reprendre le bullet
donc avec ce score il perçait une petite
fourchette mais attention cavaliers
fuite take away
et et du cou et
paquet fois ci c'est simple soit parce
qu'il a sacrifié une pièce quand même
pour deux options il ya deux pions passé
lié mais après il faut qu'on fait dans
cinq ça risque d'être d'être re
découvrir j'ai une pièce de moi mais je
te qui ont passé et celles consenties au
match contre contre aronian ou à renier
le faisait beaucoup de lest indienne et
il y avait très souvent des pions passé
comme sa maman dans l'autre ça serve as
chris kelly clark beaucoup trop vite il
a rendu la pièce en tête contre les murs
bas c'est bien mais ça se termine avec
un point de plus pour nous sommes donc
clairement le joueur chinois ici car
l'opposition pour mettre nos créations
il domine clairement clermont se
maintient franchement digne dans tout
les cadences
dans toutes ses cadences bijoux lui un
tour et l'unsa mais d'avoir des chèques
ménaka et riki nakaya rapide
et
on va avoir encore une fois ils rentrent
dans ces 20 dernières secondes il ya un
type souvent il un avantage mais un
fonds plus facilement à concret c'est
pas évident mais chacun un plan passé
ici et cavaliers qui est très très fort
en c6 qui comprend toutes les colonies
ouverte de la tour ouais ne peut pas se
faire couler par ton cv puisqu'il y
aurait des tactiques des canadiens celle
des fourchettes ouais alors la guinness
donne le pion mais c'est pas très grave
le port en fonction il lui a pas très
très loin ninon aujourd'hui a
profité d'un fort il ya un petit peu aux
fraises mais kg 3
tout ça est chaque fois là il a du coup
trajets soient réelles faisant attention
à ta victoire contre les dangers d'un
match 4 il va retrouver pas peur c'est
très chaud la naca qui tente le tout
pour le tout et des rois de dim qui
partent et il veut pas du retour des
huitièmes il a pas de clause ouverte ici
les fourchettes là c'est manger manger
qu'avait il est monstrueux
qu'est-ce qu'il ya un fort bon ce match
digne sein de foule elles seront closes
il avancé
j'ai essayé un guide robin 8 prises
prises dans le b 4
non il y aura des enfants dans promis je
pense qu'un des quatre minimes
et dunkerque est pas content ça y est ça
y est
mais la même même souffle a vu quoi
j'y crois pas à quoi ok plus de plus que
pour pour ding est qui s'est tenue dans
ce match peut créer la surprise
il est vraiment très très proches
ok donc tu repars sur il repart sur
d'heure sur deux positions un petit peu
chelou accablant je regrette d'avoir la
tête du gabon
je vais avoir le savoir il se mange un
peu les doigts mais mais
[Musique]
bon après la panne à recycler que ça
enfin si mais
j'avais bien bienvenus
ouais il remarche parce que bien sûr il
atteint d'un article
il commet cet été un petit document là
il va à tout prix la gagne
non mais franchement
la finale enfin dean qui sans mac à un
vrai rapport
n'aurait pas parié avec contrairement
avec l'addiction j'en ai jamais parié
sur sorties probantes naka bon ce match
est
maintenant bien dans le match quand on
est parti pour ce qu'il a montré naka et
est largement meilleur dans ce match là
excuse-moi digoin et et il mérite
largement de gagner ce match et se
serait même presque injuste qui ne
gagnent pas j'avais déjà vu la qualité
des parties qui nous fait avancer
c'est
c'est un bon deal convention français
plaisir quoi parce que il a fait une
série de mauvais résultats après d après
le coït tout ce qui est
à droite candidat etc et du coup le voir
jouer à son plus haut niveau pacifique
icare teaser comme tu le dis que c'est
vraiment un des meilleurs joueurs du
monde et c'est
mon cas je sais ce qu'ils avaient pris
1,4 km et 30 on prend on incarne qui
évidemment qu'on veut mieres dit fait
une bonne partie a poussé poussé cet
add-on oui l'afrique il a raté mais il
avait enjoint indignation prix souef
celle d'un des trois tout est fini a
terminé m ca entre 6 et d'allégations a
fini aussi faux procès de gestion certes
tout est perdu
donc les ya plus de est-ce que l'intérêt
de du de digues de continuer la partie
ou de table n'est pas après une aline
elle ils ont intérêt à faire durer ouais
mais aboya karting score bien sûr bien
sûr
je pensais pas que dit il pouvait faire
sa crise et là après moi ça va mais tu
es très la halle à la casse qui ferait
c'est que il fait sa tombe et là a dit
me regarde et va il le fait et c'est à
dire jamais se dire
je crois que sa victoire dans le match
c'est avec toi j'avais dit que dit il le
ferait pas
d'après moi ce n'est pas déterminant
mais après cette petite pause bah c'est
moche mais ok c'est parti du joueur son
ak contre un accueil faut le faire parce
que le tout en moins c'est ce qui
accapare donc une boulette et les pièces
blanc j'ai l'impression la plus efficace
que jusqu'à la rampe beats
parole à ces petits ces petits royales
far west j'aime bien pour les blancs
tendus très gros centre une compensation
d'avoir perdu du temps pour vos qu'elle
est
à 100 db 3a 3b c'est logique l'attaqué
sur les deuxièmes avec le blanc
c'est trop h4 qu'avec rejetant ces trois
récits et plus tard avec mes quatre bien
sûr
attention comme ça peut être compliqué
ici un haut depuis le 4 il peut être des
fois un peu faible faire attention à 110
quand même dû cavaler g46 forçant
le faut être échangé j'en mangerais bien
forme car je crois de gens
après mon ange là ça peut être
thématiques avec des échanges et les
fous pour installer un cavalier en
bessin qui avec ce très fort en bessin
car si un peu fou qu'a second attaquant
la faiblesse des six vins c'est encore
une position agréable
qui va partir après c'est après c'est
une position type estime diane tu as
appris j'ai simplement chinois et si
jamais les blancs on pas créer vraiment
de choses à la dame ça peut être très
bien si tentante pour les noirs en fait
là maintenant je préfère le noir
quelques points avant essayer de mettre
un blocus sur le cadre voilà c'est ça
on est un peu affaibli et casques blancs
j'ai essayé de jouer à kiev 3 je pense
du coup pour consolider
caïds et 5 peut-être
ils échangent pour garder le focus soit
15,4 la romaine d'une cabale et orgue et
là il va remettre là il a vraiment ce
qui devrait essayer de faire c'est
changer les fous 15 manches
lahonta je serai très clairement
à bas le cavalier dominerait
complètement le foulée j'imagine qu'avec
un mois et dakar mais
la foule bien qu'il ya une semaine a
besoin que j'aurais vous savez je pense
dans tous les cas pour garder des pièces
et la traque de 7 sur un fougerais froid
peut être pas toujours joseph iii avec
les bleus
attention gros h 4 34 qui menacent et du
coup ils avancent que l'option pour
passe le ferment de gênes
là c'est un peu malin cela pour ding il
est mal autant
et la position est dur c'est chaud ça
peut basculer des deux côtés je pense
ses positions très complexe parce que
j'ai quatre ça un jour ça peut être un
coup ci devra fixer sur les cases
blanches par des objets de le faire du
fait pas vraiment fait surclassement
aura pas de problème normalement enfin
tu peux pas arriver que tout soit 15
mois vous y tient toute la position
charge en plus nous de rien et voir si
un mec je peux essayer parce qu'un jour
je peux essayer de faire un tour c'est 2
et b4 essayer de 2 autour c'est un non
lieu ou un faire attention à ça le roi
comme passeur ah bah oui le roi blanc il
est bien sûr moins bien que le roi noir
mais ok peut-être les deux vont attendre
badiou après cette leçon de martin tu
vois du coup
la carte d'accueil prend des risques il
veut a gagné et il y attend il a joué il
a fait un prénom je vais entrer c'est
fait
j'ai pas s'est pas trompé là il a voulu
jouer très vite
et dhaka attaque maintenant sur les deux
ailes gens restent naguère prendre la
main ici les deux toutes les deux elles
sont ouvertes j'ai pas trop proche de
wall a peut-être tour là est entré deux
tons black line up de défaut de ces
échecs prises après cet homme g2 qui
peut arriver une égalisation genre à
partir pour dakar ils étaient
impressionnants pendant cette tournée il
ya tout reprend d'un prend et matt
cependant quand même avec la dame c'est
fini
dimizio jusqu'au bois
de la smat ya au moins ce mérite
hier combien de temps du coup là il
reste 10 minutes
ok dix minutes et s'est terminée à
gagner à voir 12 partout
10 bat avec son roi
alors attention que si jamais j'arrive à
manger
ce serait
la 10ème attendant quatre matches quatre
à oui
voilà le changement et il continue à
fondre à la vienne une autogreffe six
noms moquer france comptant elle a fait
tomber
la faille tomber zing le voir c'est fini
en fait mais bon est-ce que c'est
vraiment l'intérêt de djing maintenant
de faire passer en fait il fait ça parce
que son but c'est qu'elle moindre partie
possible la plus de chances qu'il
atteint réserve dont une partie que sur
ok donc 12-12 macaques qui
recolle au score il reste neuf minutes
les gars neuf minutes pour seulement
deux matches c'est intense mais on voit
que maintenant maka est un peu dans son
petit jardin il
s'est départi très compliqué ouais moi
tu n'as plus proche des deux côtés à
chaque parent clame en clamant et il
reste pas beaucoup de parties avec 9
minutes il reste qu'entre deux et trois
parties max donc et tout peut se passer
encore tout fait à celle importante qui
passe exactement et pour le moral ça
serait quand même bien que dilma galles
parce que la safer trois parties
d'affilée a
quasiment là mme à la fin du match ce
serait quand même dommage de le voir
perdre maintenant si c'est
ça en tout cas j'aime beaucoup sa
pollution encore une fois le foutoir qui
est une grosse poubelle comme d'hab
la cas avec ces fous c'est un truc de
malade à chaque fois ce barrage un jeune
allemand c'est un four b2 qui laqué pour
y dérober quatre et là c'est un tout et
3 et j'aime beaucoup la position des
noirs d'un match 4 km et f4
orienté sur les droits
et en tout cas c'est c'est un beau mâle
sans franchement
très dommage
c'est le plus beau match qu'on ait eu
depuis depuis le début un revirement
car il avait enfin la fourchette il a vu
la fourchette qu'est ce qui les fera
quand même
c'était c'était c'était bien sûr une
blague
et je voudrais avant que michael meure à
la fourche ali surtout sa forme pour le
droit ouais cinq pièces 11 ans et un
variateur
ménaka en défense il est quand même
fallu table et
franchement il peut se passer beaucoup
beaucoup de choses là et de cavaliers
prend un choix qui peut arriver du franc
jeu 4 tu as juste un qui peut arriver
derrière
bien sûr il faut garder les dames un
talent et de son jeune talent attaque
août aux congés 4,7 l'avez ratée pour
projet cap magnifique playzone irène qui
l'accueille deux pions défini coins
chauds et mangani maka qui fait la
gueule
by souris sourit il arrivait il est bon
joueur l'adoption pas et même plus assez
il reste 7 minutes donc ne peut pas
faire pour gagner la digue doit surtout
pas la laisser s'échapper celle ci avant
biegler sur un abandon c'est l'abandon
n'a qu'à intéressant cette stratégie
d'abandonner aliciens bah ouais il faut
abandonner il faut que en fait mach à
vue qui perd au score il faut qu'il ait
le plus de temps possible pour se
refaire à jamais cette pause pour les
noirs en cours que j'ai pas mal et bien
c'est presque une balle de match 6 ces
gars là je prends ça peut être finir
parce qu'une partie des
cigales crs a peut être fini parce que
du coup la partie qui va durer qui va
durer environ quatre minutes il rappelé
environ 2 3 minutes pour une dernière
partie avec plus de hausse quand ce sera
terminé donc naka est obligé de faire au
moins une nuit du 6
mai
est ce qu'il va faire le brakna cas
certainement au smic en tout cas la can
ne peut pas perdre cela n'a pas droit de
la perdre pour le match encore une
position plutôt agréable à jeu pour les
blancs ces petits cavaliers 4 jeux à 3
39 ans il va échanger un jour qualifié
at-il ouais non c'est l'évolution ou
randy il est très très très serein parce
que c'était le même genre tout le temps
contre aronian et franchement
franchement je me bourre pour en fait
attendu joue avec les blancs dirige snap
physiologique non mais en fait il a vu
faire des troncs sur carte blanche les
parents des risques aussi n'empêche à
sacrifier des pions plusieurs fois pour
l'attack initiative
au but cela et sk parc avec ce qui peut
arriver avec une sorte de bad du couloir
j'ai pas prenne trop de temps quand même
hein c'est un bullet ouais il faut il
faut qu'ils prennent leur chance à un
coût intéressant avant d'avancer
meilleur que l'ordinateur tâche
ingénieurs créer un génie non mais
sérieux
auquel il a perdu un pion mais sait pas
s'il ya encore il ya la colonne c'est la
coloc bs4 bien joué on va fixer la
faiblesse sur quatre kamal et d un
cavalier de 3 pour fixer sur des 5 et f5
d'étape comme un petit avantage plutôt
pour les noirs ici mais encore infondées
position à double tranchant les deux
joueurs peuvent y en a qu'un qui doit
absolument gagner la partie on avait dit
pour les l'agression car elle est à 5
attention qu'avec concept qui peut
arriver
ici oussama toute façon ce match ce qui
est trop forte demande sont curieux ils
jouaient leur 4e cavani gcb 5 3 quand
même arrivé 5 août a par contre pas
bastien
je commence à
redoubler arrivant j'ai très très chaud
sur un petit royaume qui joue vite il
est pas très bien autant version
française thales
sur trois et sept manger aller en cours
du genre mach 6.5 au chocolat noir mais
la carne macarons défense c'est vraiment
humain
ça sent vraiment la partie décisive là
parce qu'elle dure en plus sévères
championne round a rien de sûr il reste
quatre minutes je pense pas que ça dure
encore quatre minutes sa cavale et
fourchette fourchette dean qui rate la
fourche est leur intérêt fourchette
hockey dame assise peut-être donc nos
resserrement très bien des
noms mais c'est cela qui est dominant
tours de sa marche pas encore des nattes
le pion à 6
tours c'est carrément qui ont la
pression
naguère il va peut-être réussir et
changer d'âme mais si j'ai changé d'avis
sera en finale qu'un pont mais en vous
pas changer d'avis bien sûr à vous on
veut pas le voir ça bah c'est ce qui va
se passer ouais mais du coup là je peux
me laisser six peut-être parce que
prescrit ce tournage est trop lâche pour
manger ici c'est un peu chaud qu'à
valider m6 qui avait les bassins merpati
la paix rhdp la nuit c'est pas mal quand
higuain bas du second c'est pas si mal
parce que là il ya un match aussi d'un
gars qui veut la jouer regardez tous
soit annuler c'était pas mal pour ding
parce que du coup il est sur au moins
les au moins un magasin quoi enfin au
moins des
chats
2 il a évité la fourchette attention et
le temps qui s'écoule encore cette
finale est hyper chaude non c'est là il
perd le pion au
[Musique]
[Rires]
5e à priori là ils arrivaient d'higuain
fait deux trois quatre ans chacun c'est
pas le pied grippage de l'histoire ça va
non mais bon tu perds un temps près
texte est content quoi s'agit-il comme
le souligne qu il a raté une fourchette
était la fourchette de match ouais c'est
la faute de main commise est finie
échelle j'aimerais l'amener là pour le
coup si toi mais c'est pas facile encore
ce qui a été manquée de cavalli effect
partout c'est insupportable
nul à répétition il reste deux minutes
il reste deux minutes nakaa obligations
gagnac les blancs pour pour faire ça
sans les prolongations ça sent les
prolongations je crois qu'on va changer
beau match pour faire les prolongations
celui qui veut se conservera jusqu'à 4
heures du matin
pour perdre magasin je trouve
insupportable
ok donc la digue est si énorme il reste
une minute et 1,5 donc c'est sûr que
c'est la der enfin la dermatite espagnol
ouais
il sut partir de 10 leçons là dans le
tchat qu'est-ce qui aura une pause après
je pense qu'un petit copain
qui sont ils vont me parle dans
l'oreillette
il est quand même à une minute de la